bonjour à tous hier soir les sénateurs
ont adopté le projet de loi relatif à
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est un
texte fondateur d'abord lorsqu'il
définit ce qu'est l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est une manière
d'entreprendre qu'une recherche pas le
profit à tout prix qui réinvestit tous
ces bénéfices dans l'entreprise et dans
la gouvernance et démocratique ce texte
était relativement consensuel à
l'exception des articles 11 et 12
articles qui prévoit la formation
préalable des salariés en cas de cession
d'entreprise afin de favoriser la
reprise de cette entreprise par ces
mêmes salariés l'UMP notamment était
vent debout à propos de cet article
considérant qu'il s'agissait d'une
atteinte à la confidentialité nécessaire
à tout rachat d'entreprises c'est cet
article 11 l'examen de cet article 11
que je vous propose de voir ce matin
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
à ces articles 11 ces articles 11 et 12
du projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui
trouve un juste équilibre il trouve un
juste équilibre entre ceux qui ne
veulent rien changer qui disent tout va
bien madame la marquise mais je le
rappelle que 50000 emplois cela a déjà
été dit 50000 emplois sont détruits
chaque année faute de repreneurs
d'entreprises en bonne santé puisque
nous ne parlons là que des entreprises
en bonne santé les entreprises qui
rencontrent des difficultés il y a
d'autres procédures donc il s'agit bien
d'entreprises qui sont tout à fait
viables donc ceux qui ne veulent pas
changer et puis ceux au contraire qui
voudraient qu'on aille plus loin et qui
considère que le droit d'information des
salariés n'est pas suffisant et certains
même souhaitant aller jusqu'à un droit
de préférence
entre des repreneurs pour préférer les
salariés donc je pense nous pensons que
ces articles 11 et 12 trouvent en juste
équilibre pour ces entreprises en bonne
santé je voudrais également rappeler que
ça concerne essentiellement les petites
et moyennes entreprises et
particulièrement les entreprises de
moins de 5 ans de salariés qui n'ont pas
de comité d'entreprise puisque
normalement entre 50 et 2 et 249
salariés il y a des comités d'entreprise
et donc c'est dans ce cadre-là que
l'information doit se faire donc s'il
s'agit bien de ces petites entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés qui sont
concernés et ces entreprises de moins
que 50 concernés ont le moins de 50
salariés qui sont concernés on voit bien
le rôle qu'elle joue dans les
territoires même dans des territoires en
difficulté des entreprises en bonne
santé dans des territoires en difficulté
autour de ces entreprises c'est toute
une vie qui se développe et qui se
maintient donc il faut vraiment donner
cette cette possibilité aux salariés
d'être informé alors
mes chers collègues je n'aurais pas
je ne peux pas croire que vous défendiez
le principe selon lequel quand on garde
l'information pour soi on a plus de
pouvoir parce que c'est pas ça qui joue
dans les entreprises et je voudrais vous
rappeler que c'est un président de la
République qui a dit qu'il fallait faire
l'alliance du capital et de l'emploi
pour permettre à tous
patrons comme salarié de défendre la
France et de travailler pour la France
ce président de la République il
s'appelait Charles de Gaulle
merci madame monsieur la Mini
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues concernant
cet amendement qui avait été présenté en
fin de matinée par notre collègue madame
Lamure et je dirais
au niveau de la suppression de certains
article 11
d'une certaine manière moi je le
soutiendrai aussi je le soutiendrai bon
nous avons aussi des témoignages de
chefs d'entreprise dans nos départements
respectifs je prends l'exemple de la
CGPE du département des Ardennes
qui s'oppose aussi pour qu'il indique
que
cet article aurait un impact négatif sur
les entreprises sur les TPE PME de notre
territoire bon cet argument peut tenir
je respecte tout à l'heure
l'intervention de qualité de monsieur le
rapporteur et de monsieur le ministre
vous l'avez fait avec beaucoup de
passion que je respecte tout à fait mais
de l'autre côté je crois qu'il y a ce
que vivent au quotidien les chefs
d'entreprise relayées par leur
confédération de petites moyennes
entreprises parce que bon c'est indiqué
quand même je ne l'invente pas c'est je
crois que c'est des témoignages qui sont
écrits dans lequel nous avons été
destinataires pour un bon nombre de
collègues
indique que développer moderniser le
secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire à côté des autres formes
d'entreprises tout en respectant les
autres secteurs de l'économie en évitant
toute forme de distorsion de concurrence
peut être souhaitable certes je crois
qu'elle a été dit mais de l'autre côté
il faut être prudent
vraiment très prudent par rapport à
certaines attitudes qui remettent en
cause la survie de nombreuses
TPE PME du fait des règles qui
s'appliquent de manière inégale et
injustifiée je crois que ça a été
rappelé par un certain nombre de nos
collègues les chefs d'entreprise
réellement sont très inquiets sur le
dispositif prévu notamment cet article
11 du projet de loi qui crée réellement
un nouveau droit préalable d'information
des salariés lors de la transmission
d'une entreprise saine donc je dirais
des mesures d'opposition à cette mesure
qui d'une certaine manière apparaît pour
complexifier réellement les
transmissions et qui risqueraient de les
faire échouer ce qui va d'une certaine
manière à l'inverse de l'objectif qui
est
affiché la transmission en effet
réellement un acte qui se prépare à long
terme on cite généralement un délai de 5
années de plus dans les très petites
entreprises PME ou la notion d'hommes
clés et crucial cela a été rappelé
l'information selon laquelle ce dernier
quitte la tête de son entreprise peut
être dans certains cas de nature à la
déstabiliser donc il est donc important
si le chef d'entreprise ne juge
nécessaire que la préparation d'une
transmission se réalise réellement
discrètement par ailleurs il convient
aussi que le dirigeant doit conserver
l'entière maîtrise du choix de son
successeur voilà je j'arrêterai là un
petit peu les arguments que un certain
nombre de collègues se sont exprimés
aussi avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
passion et je crois que un moment donné
je crois qu'il faut rester très prudent
en la matière donc je suis aussi réservé
et je soutiendrai cet amendement qui
vise à la suppression de cet article 11
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
madame linman
mes chers collègues tout à l'heure de
nos collègues alsaciens nous a expliqué
que tout était parfaitement fait par la
Chambre de commerce de son département
des métiers des métiers
mais de l'autre côté de la frontière mon
cher collègue
vous collez également
dans les entreprises de plus de cinq
salariés sont dans l'obligation
d'informer leurs salariés en amont de la
transmission de leur entreprise et on ne
peut pas dire que nos collègues de
l'autre côté de la frontière soit sur ce
sujet mais je vous dis vous pouvez le
vérifier ne soit paralysé par je ne sais
quel secret qui ne serait pas respecté
ou pas des salariés et chevlés qui
seraient là pour détruire leur outil de
travail donc la réalité c'est que là où
ça se met en oeuvre ça fonctionne vous
nous dites que les chambres de métiers
font tous qu'elles peuvent je veux bien
le croire
sauf que ça fait maintenant 10-15 ans
qu'on a régulièrement tous lu des
rapports sur l'enjeu de la transmission
et de la reprise d'entreprise dans notre
pays que l'on fait des Colocs divers et
variés qui a effectivement eu un progrès
dans l'information qui ont été qui a pu
être donnés force est de constater que
toute une série d'entreprises sont sans
repreneur alors on peut avoir deux
thèses la vôtre c'est de dire elles sont
pas reprenables
la nôtre est de dire pour une large part
d'entre elles sont viables
et s'il n'y a pas de repreneur c'est pas
parce que l'entreprise n'est pas capable
de survivre c'est soit parce que
l'information près de repreneur d'hiver
n'a pas été suffisamment recherchée soit
parce que la rentabilité de l'entreprise
n'est pas à comparer à deux offres vous
avez du capital disponible vous voulez
acheter des entreprises vous prenez
celle qui a le plus de rendement
financiers
mais même dans le mais je m'excuse je
connais des PME où il y a à reprendre
des PMI industriels par exemple où il y
a besoin mais je m'excuse monsieur je
connais bien des sujets de PMI
industriels qui ont des problèmes de
reprise et qui comme elles ne sont pas
les plus attractives dans leurs branches
par rapport à d'autres ne sont pas
privilégiés par toute une série de
repreneurs en revanche
elle pourrait être viable et en
particulier souvent vous avez donné un
autre collègue monsieur Savary je crois
donner l'exemple de cadre qui dans
l'entreprise soit en situation de
pouvoir le reprendre mais c'est pas
monsieur Savary parce que ça se fasse
bien maintenant et qu'il y en a encore
50 000 qui ne fonctionnent pas qu'il
faut pas élargir le champ vous nous
dites chiche je vous dis aussi chiche
votez notre amendement nos textes
refusaient retirer votre amendement et à
partir de là nous ferons le bilan dans
un an ou deux je ne crois pas que nos
chefs d'entreprise soient angoissés par
cette perspective et je pense que la
plupart des chefs d'entreprise ont
besoin d'avoir la certitude que la
nation les accompagne pour la
transmission de leur bien et le et la
reprise de leur entreprise la plupart
d'entre eux ont envie qu'elle survivre
il y a les mauvaises exemples les
mauvais exemple qui ont été donnés par
Monsieur berasou qui existe et qu'il
faut conjurer mais il y a aussi tous
ceux qui sont un peu en difficulté de
trouver parce que aujourd'hui le capital
est rare les gens qui peuvent investir
ne sont pas toujours disponibles à
l'instant T au moment et à l'endroit où
il faut et que dans ce cas là
l'information des salariés peut être un
atout donc nous je vous le rappelle nos
collègues également le font et ils ne
s'emportent pas mal
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Goulet
je vais me désolidariser de mes
camarades qui ont signé cet amendement
de suppression que je ne voterai pas je
voudrais quand même vous expliquer
pourquoi
d'abord parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de
droits du travail et des entreprises
avec Jean-Jacques du Pérou et notamment
Maurice Cohen dans le droit des comités
d'entreprise et que le droit des
salariés dans l'entreprise c'est quelque
chose qui est utile alors ce que vous
proposez aujourd'hui qui est une
information ou des salariés préables
session c'est pratiquement un appel à
candidature en réalité pour pour une
reprise ce serait d'ailleurs un terme
qui serait pratiquement plus exact que
l'information alors sur le principe je
suis extrêmement favorable sur les
modalités de l'article je suis un peu
plus réservé je suis un peu plus réservé
sur les délais je suis un peu plus
réservé sur l'accompagnement des
salariés pour faire des propositions
parce que à part il y aura des
amendements ensuite mais il faudra un
expert comptable il faudra connaître la
situation de l'entreprise si vous voulez
que les salariés puissent faire une
proposition il faudra bien qu'il soit
encadré d'une façon ou d'une autre c'est
pas parce qu'il travaille dans une
entreprise c'est pas parce qu'ils
connaissent de produits c'est pas parce
qu'ils connaissent l'entreprise qui sont
capables de faire une proposition de
reprise et en cela il est évident que ce
texte doit être totalement amélioré et
revu bon l'autre chose c'est les
problèmes de confidentialité qui se
posent à l'évidence et je pense que la
disposition qui qui vise à la discrétion
on est évidemment pas suffisante et donc
si vous voulez en résumé pour ne pas
rallonger les débats je ne voterai pas
l'amendement de suppression et je pense
que pour le coup votre texte étant
soumis à une procédure normale on aura
plusieurs navettes je crois qu'il faut
absolument
améliorer le dispositif mais en tous les
cas moi je suis extrêmement favorable à
ce principe qui donne plus
d'informations aux salariés que les
modalités de cette information doivent
être sérieusement revues de façon à
rendre cette information efficace dans
l'objectif qui est celui de la loi
c'est-à-dire la reprise parce que si
c'est une information strictosensus et
une information ils peuvent la voir à un
moment ou à un autre et pourquoi pas
mais si c'est une information dans
l'objectif de reprendre alors je crois
que le dispositif et les modalités
d'application sont sérieusement à revoir
soit ce type en passant c'est la raison
pour laquelle je maps j'aimerais sur
cette amendement de suppression et que
je ne le voterai pas merci Monsieur le
Ministre de la parole
juste quelques éléments mais
ils sont pas très nombreux pour aussi
vous relater des
discussions que j'ai eu avec les
différents partenaires sociaux qu'ils
soient membres d'organisation patronales
ou aux membres d'organisation salariés
je l'ai dit les cinq confédérations
salariés sont favorables à ce droit
d'information ça compte
ça compte et je ne compte que les
organisations représentatives et je vous
fais pas la liste de celle qui ils sont
favorables elles y sont toutes
favorables ça compte dans les
discussions qu'on a eu avec les
organisations patronales je me permets
de faire quelques différences les
organisations patronales toutes ensemble
se sont inquiétés pour l'essentiel des
trois représentatives l'UPR la CGPME et
le Medef du principe de ce droit
d'information est monté
pour que sur des mobiles on va dire
assez différents en réalité ce que je
constate après discussion et après que
nous ayons avancé dans ce texte c'est
que nous avons un bien des égards
rassuré laquelle des organisations l'UA
notamment sur le fait que quand il y a
des ayants droit familiaux que la
succession s'organise dans un fonds de
commerce dans la famille le droit
d'information notre pas en vigueur en
tout cas ces mesures là sont écartées
donc aujourd'hui nous avons non pas un
enthousiasme de l'UPR en faveur de cette
mesure-là ce serait mentir que de le
dire mais je crois bon nombre des
inquiétudes de l'UPA tel qu'elles ont
été formulées en 7 lettres qui ont pu
être levés j'en veux pour preuve le fait
d'avoir croisé il y a quelques jours
encore le président de l'UA sur ces
questions qui n'a pas manifesté en tout
cas de d'opposition qui était
d'opposition désormais farouche à ce
texte après
incontestablement et j'ai essayé
d'écouter les remarques qui étaient
faites et elles sont pas toutes J'ai
jamais pensé cela celle de la CGPME en
particulier
tombé de jeunes saisons et déconnecté de
la réalité on a des chefs d'entreprise
qui sont des chefs d'entreprise qui
incontestablement aujourd'hui s'inquiète
des conditions de transmission etc etc
nous avons essayé de tenir compte aussi
de leur point de vue mais je veux vous
relater aussi une réalité je reprends ma
PME de menuiserie dans laquelle moi
patron je bosse six jours sur 7
pour faire mon 3%
ou honnêtement cette entreprise là c'est
aussi pour moi patron une forme de
servitude à l'égard de mon temps de
loisir
et regarde de ce que macapare l'activité
la vie de mon entreprise c'est une
réalité vous la partagez
la vie de ses patrons de PME c'est pas
la vie dorée de quelques grands patrons
d'entreprises côté qui viennent
aujourd'hui expliquer que c'est pas bien
la transmission dans les moins de 50
alors qu'il n'y connaissent pas plus que
du bon nombre de ceux qui en parlent
beaucoup la réalité de la vie d'un
patron de PME dans ses territoires là
c'est une vie qui n'est pas une vie
facile et au moment de la transmission
qu'est-ce qui intéressera le maire
qu'est-ce qui intéressera la Chambre de
commerce qu'est ce qui est intéressant
les clients de cette PME qu'est-ce qui
intéressera les salariés c'est que
l'activité se maintiennent mais qui a
pas forcément beaucoup de candidats pour
reprendre le flambeau quand on sait que
la gestion d'un certain nombre de ces
entreprises en période de crise repose
sur un investissement une application
quand on reprend quitte extrêmement
lourde
et c'est aussi une réalité c'est qu'il y
a pas toujours les candidats pour ce
genre de job là et en quoi notre droit
d'information effectivement madame la
sénatrice
s'apparente aussi un appel à candidature
c'est que qui mieux que celui qui joue
son emploi donc sa vie
par le maintien de l'entreprise et le
plus on va dire non pas disposer parce
qu'encore faut-il être formé on passe
pas de fait de gérer l'imprimante offset
de l'imprimerie pendant 20 ans à la
gestion d'une entreprise du jour au
lendemain mais qui mieux que les
salariés le collectif est souvent le
plus intéressant à maintenir l'activité
personne souvent
et c'est à partir de ce raisonnement là
que nous avons travaillé j'entends les
remarques qui peuvent être faites là
encore sur discrétion confidentialité on
sait aligné sur le droit du travail
existant les obligations qui sont celles
des ce qui seront celles désormais des
salariés saisis en tout cas détenteurs
de ce droit d'information nous avons
essayé de construire une stratégie donc
je le redis vise à maintenir l'activité
économique après on trouvera toujours
toutes sortes de
d'arguments pour penser que un droit
nouveau sa complexifie mais à ce rythme
là il y aurait pas de ce il y aurait pas
de délégué du personnel dans les moins
de 50 parce que tout complexifie et s'il
fallait essayer la fameuse
métaphore du renard libre dans un
poulailler où les poules sont libres
mais sauf que le renard est libre de
circuler de manger les poules donc voilà
ce que nous ne voulons pas nous voulons
nous essayer de construire des droits et
je le redis j'étais sensible à
l'argument de Madame de montess même si
ce qui était frappé du Saut du bon sens
l'alliance capital travail c'est Charles
de Gaulle le général de Gaulle qui a
construit un discours dessus je dis pas
que nous sommes les héritiers de Charles
de Gaulle en faisant cela
mais ce serait bien que vous vous en
rappeliez un peu plus parfois vous-même
voilà mais je le dis parce que c'est on
peut tous invoquer quelques figures
emblématiques et moi j'irai
tranquillement mabrité j'ai pas eu
l'audace de citer Jaurès et Blum ici
donc je vous parle que du général de
Gaulle mais pour vous dire quoi que sur
cette alliance capitale travail le
raisonnement il était de dire que sur le
terrain dans l'entreprise l'alliance des
forces productives c'est à dire les
salariés et les entrepreneurs c'est la
meilleure manière de maintenir l'emploi
est-ce que nous essayons de faire c'est
le combiner l'intérêt du chef
d'entreprise à vendre pardon de le
répéter donc de réaliser une plus-value
et l'intérêt du salarié a que ce qu'on
emploie soit maintenu en rachetant
l'entreprise dans laquelle jusqu'ici la
travailler c'est le sens de cette mesure
et je crois et je le redis qu'elle est
bonne pour l'économie française bonne
pour l'emploi et bonne pour le droit du
travail dans ce pays
monsieur le Président Mezard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
notre groupe unanimement votre Appa
cette amendement de ses amendements de
suppression
nous avons
je pense comme vous tous travailler sur
ce texte
nous sommes
très attachés à des principes
le droit de propriété la liberté
individuelle mais aussi l'intérêt
général le service du public le service
au public et je dirais que notre
tradition c'est d'essayer de trouver un
équilibre entre ses grands principes qui
gouvernent notre République je ne me
référerai pas au créateur de la
Cinquième République ce n'est pas notre
histoire à nous
mais
dans ce dans ce texte
ce qui est révélateur c'est ce qui
persiste d'une caractéristique française
c'est ce climat de méfiance entre les
chefs d'entreprise et les salariés et je
ne dis pas que tout est de la
responsabilité d'un côté ou de l'autre
et par rapport à ce que disait tout à
l'heure notre collègue Marie-Noël linman
sur ce qui se passe par exemple en
Allemagne je ne dis pas non plus
toujours qu'il faut se référer à
l'exemple allemand mais nous avons nous
avons nous avons un réel problème
tant que ces relations se vivront comme
un combat il est normal que les salariés
défendent leurs intérêts il est normal
que le chef d'entreprise défendent ces
intérêts mais il faut sortir d'une
certaine guerre de tranchées à laquelle
tout le monde concourt depuis très
longtemps depuis trop longtemps nous ne
sommes pas de ceux en tout cas la
majorité de mon groupe qui sont pour le
droit de préférence ça aurait des
conséquences néfastes sur le plan
économique ça aurait des inconvénients
sur blanc constitutionnel qui sont
évidents par contre informer
les salariés moi je considère que c'est
normal vous savez bon il y a déjà sur un
certain nombre d'entreprises importantes
par les dispositions de l'article
l2323-19 du Code du travail
l'information et la consultation des
comités d'entreprise ça existe je
rappelle à nos collègues que lorsqu'il y
a une session de fonds de commerce on
informe dans les journaux de d'annonces
légales pour que les créanciers puissent
réagir éventuellement et pourquoi les
salariés n'auraient ne bénéficierez pas
de l'information que le chef
d'entreprise souhaite vendre ça n'est
pas quand même quelque chose d'anormal
réfléchissons calmement c'est pas
quelque chose qui mettra en danger
véritablement les entreprises parce que
soit ils ont déjà des informations parce
que le chef d'entreprise en donne soit
il y a une volonté de cacher la
situation avec des motifs qui sont
toujours tout à fait louable c'est moi
j'ai exercé la profession d'avocat
pendant 38 ans j'ai plaidé pour des
salariés j'ai plaidé pour des chefs
d'entreprise j'ai souvenance quand même
de cession d'entreprise ou le chef
d'entreprise informe après la vente les
salariés pour aboutir dans certains cas
à des catastrophes économiques donc tout
n'est pas blanc d'un côté noir de
l'autre et l'information par rapport à
ceux qui travaillent dans une entreprise
moi je ne suis pas d'accord nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec la notion
d'intention il faut sécuriser cette
information cette information qui est
donnée aux salariés mais sur le fond la
véritable difficulté c'est d'aider et de
former les salariés à être avoir la
possibilité de reprendre voilà le vrai
problème de fond mais donner une
information vous savez aujourd'hui avec
les bouleversements aussi les moyens de
communication se refusaient à donner
l'information qu'on veut vendre je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse durablement
s'accrocher à cette situation actuelle
et je crois qu'il faut que nous
avantions calmement en respectant les
intérêts des uns et des autres ce sera
d'ailleurs l'objet de l'amendement que
je soutiendrai tout à l'heure
merci chers collègues je vais mettre
voir ses amendements j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de secrétaire public par
le groupe UMP sur les abonnements numéro
7 rectifiés et 165 de suppression de
l'article 11 on va procéder au scrutin
public dans les conditions de notre
règlement
j'avais que les vous êtes vous aviez
votre explication de vote avant la
suspension donc il y a plus
non
après les explications de vote il y a
qu'une seule explication de vote par
sénateur
le scrutin est ouvert
et clos
je demande au secrétaire
de procéder au dépouillement
mes chers collègues les amendements donc
soumis à ce scrutin public résultats du
vote nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 345 pour l'adoption
167 contre
168 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
sur la suite des amendements je suis
saisi pour une discussion commune d'un
certain nombre d'amendements dont le 3
rectifié bis présenté par Monsieur
Retailleau
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mais mes chers collègues je
voudrais d'abord m'excuser mais
nous avons aujourd'hui et hier des
dossiers importants sur l'emploi
notamment avec Fagor Brandt et il y
avait une réunion ce matin avec les
cabinets d'Arnaud Montebourg et de
Michel Sapin pour un certain nombre
d'informations que nous devions partager
donc je n'ai pas pu être présent
néanmoins je vais présenter cette cette
amendement et je ferai au moment de du
vote de l'article une explication de
votre sur l'article sur l'article 11
pour cet amendement je voudrais
simplement dire d'ailleurs que nous
sommes vous l'avez vu monsieur le
ministre d'accord sur ce constat qu'on
partage
que bien sûr en France la transmission
c'est un enjeu ça deviendra un enjeu de
plus en plus important parce que la
pyramide des âges des chefs d'entreprise
vieillit comme la population bien sûr
que oui la non transmission d'une
entreprise
qui est saine et peut-être une perte
d'emploi c'est absolument clair et oui
enfin une reprise par des salariés peut
être une solution et la reprise d'une
entreprise par des salariés n'est pas en
France une exception souvent cela se
passe absolument naturellement mais le
dispositif que vous proposez présente
énormément d'inconvénients énormément de
lourdeurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
avec cet amendement je vous propose nous
vous proposons un dispositif plus souple
un dispositif d'ailleurs qui va
synthétiser les deux articles article 11
article 12 en un seul article
un amendement qui va en même temps
recaler finalement sur vos intentions
sur l'intention de l'exposé des motifs
le dispositif puisque dans l'exposé des
motifs vous dites la non transmission
d'entreprise saine est une source
croissante de pertes d'emploi
pour le mesurer il y a débat mais
d'accord de nombreuses entreprises
cessent en effet leur activité faute de
repreneur et quand on lit d'ailleurs le
texte de l'étude d'impact on voit que ce
qui vaut préoccupe le cœur du problème
c'est bien ces entreprises qui vont
cesser qui vont perdre de l'emploi et
qui aurait dû retrouver un repreneur
mais qui n'en trouve pas et bien
l'amendement l'amendement restreint les
obligations d'information au seul cas de
cessation d'activité pour que alors il
puisse y avoir un processus qui s'engage
à la fois c'est simple et qui reprennent
d'ailleurs finalement votre propre
dispositif mais dans ce seul cas où il
va y avoir cessation d'activité et ainsi
donc on peut écarter la rigidité la
lourdeur le problème de la
confidentialité le problème de la
complexification le problème de
l'insécurité juridique pour se
concentrer sur le problème le problème
d'ailleurs que l'exposé des motifs porte
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitions défendre cette amendement
pour faire en plus une ouverture
monsieur le ministre sur le texte que
vous nous proposez
si chers collègues
amendement numéro 98 par les membres du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
Monsieur Le Cam
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues cet amendement
servira à la fois pour l'article 11 et
l'article 12 nous l'avons nous avons
réécrit cet article effectivement un
amendement en général plus il est long
moins il a le chance d'aboutir pour
autant souhaiter le défendre dans la
mesure où il instaure un droit
d'information qui pour nous est une
avancée somme toute mesurée limitée
derrière quant à la nature d'information
puisque les salariés ne sont informés
que de l'intention de vente et non pas
accès aux offres formulées par
d'éventuels repreneurs limité dans
l'objectif aussi puisqu'il s'agit pas
d'instaurer un droit effectif de reprise
d'une entreprise par les salariés
eux-mêmes rien ne permet aux salariés
intéressés d'être prioritaire même à
offre égal par rapport à un repreneur
tiers face à l'urgence sociale qui
secoue notre pays il est absolument
nécessaire de renforcer le droit
d'information des salariés et d'accorder
à l'offre de reprise émanant d'un ou
plusieurs salariés un droit de priorité
à la double condition que cette offre
soit à la fois au moins égale à celle
formulée par d'autres repreneurs et que
le projet port par les salariés
proposent d'organiser la reprise sous
une forme coopérative enfin afin de
rendre effectif ce droit de reprise
prioritaire il convient de soutenir
économiquement les salariés dans leur
démarche à défaut de pouvoir engager des
fonds publics sous réserve de receveur
viabilités financière nous les auteurs
de cette amendement proposent donc nous
proposons d'autoriser les salariés qui
souhaitent reprendre leur entreprise
sous une forme coopérative un bénéficier
de la possibilité de débloquer trois à
participation des salariés ou aux
résultats de l'entreprise lorsqu'ils
sont investis en compte courant bloqué
ou sur un Peel un plan d'épargne
salariale ainsi que l'intéressement
lorsqu'il est placé sur un tel plan sont
normalement indisponible pendant 5 ans
je conclurai en rappelant que le droit
de priorité qui avait été un des
engagements de François Hollande
nécessitent une réelle volonté politique
pour nous les arguments tirés de
l'inconstitutionnalité ne sont pas assez
solides pour y renoncer en effet vous
avez pu considérer qu'un tel droit
pourrait être considéré comme une
atteinte au principe d'égalité au droit
de propriété à la liberté d'entreprendre
or l'appréhension ne constitue pas une
atteinte au droit de propriété puisque
le cédant ne peut arguer d'un préjudice
pour autant que l'offre soit équivalente
ni à la liberté d'entreprendre pour les
mêmes raisons
merci chers collègues amendement numéro
117 Madame La Mure merci monsieur le
Président alors c'est amendement propose
de supprimer la section 3 du présent
article puisqu'en effet si cette
nouvelle obligation d'information des
salariés et voter et bien le dialogue
naturel entre le dirigeant et le
repreneur sera inévitablement faussée et
s'ajouteront en plus le développement
inévitable de procédure et de recours
donc nous voulons ici préserver ce
moment très important qui est la vente
d'une entreprise
merci chers collègues amendement 119
rectifier c'est vous toujours madame
l'exposé des motifs de ce texte précise
que le droit d'information préalable est
destiné à pallier la non transmission
d'entreprise saine il aurait donc
vocation à s'appliquer uniquement
lorsqu'il y a il n'y a pas de repreneur
or le texte va au-delà et l'impose dans
tous les cas dans ce sirandre risque de
rendre plus difficile les transmissions
par exemple un chef d'entreprise qui
aura déjà anticipé sa session et trouver
un repreneur devra proposer à ses
salariés de lui faire une offre de
reprise qui a de grandes chances d'être
refusé et au final une reprise qui
aurait pu se faire son conflit risque
d'être entouré du fait de cette
procédure de grande tension alors nous
vous proposons donc par cet amendement
que souhaite ajouter dans les conditions
d'exemption le fait que le dirigeant est
déjà trouvé un repreneur
merci
chers collègues nous passons à
l'amendement 110 rectifié
monsieur Savary
effectivement monsieur le Président
c'est un moment on va dans le même sens
si vous permettez monsieur le Président
je peux présenter le 111 rectifié qui va
dans le même sens puisque c'est un
alinéa supplémentaire s'effectivement de
replacer ce thème au moment de la
cessation d'activité ça veut bien dire
que n'ayant pas trouvé repreneur
l'entreprise s'oriente et effectivement
le chef d'entreprise en tout cas ce
rayon vers une cessation d'activité et
c'est là qu'il y a des procédures qui
permettent de concerter les employés et
ça permet et effectivement d'engager
sans concertation sans que ce soit une
obligation dès le départ et je crois
qu'on règle le problème en tout cas ça
montre bien qu'à travers ses amendements
nous avons une volonté de trouver une
solution pour ce pour que lier une
information mais que cette information
ne soit pas rédhibitoire par rapport à
la transmission d'entreprise
merci
l'amendement
265 rectifié bis monsieur Mezard
oui monsieur le Président
mes chers monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dans la suite de ce que je
viens de d'exposer notre groupe à
souhaiter
trouver une solution qui nous a paru
plus précise juridiquement voire même
plus équilibré quant à la rédaction de
ces articles 11 et 12 et en particulier
la notion et le mot même d'intention de
vendre nous paraissait être d'un flou
juridique tout à fait évident et il nous
est apparu qu'il serait bien d'essayer
de changer cette notion et nous avons
donc fait des propositions en ce sens
nous avons bien compris qu'il y avait
deux écoles certains ce scandalisent
d'une mesure qui menacerait selon eux la
transmission des entreprises d'autres
voudraient au contraire que les
dispositions aillent plus loin et
proposent l'instauration d'une reprise
préférentielle
nous nous considérons qu'il est plus
sage d'essayer de mieux informer mais
dans la clarté juridique
cette mesure qui doit également
permettre aux salariés de formuler une
offre de reprise de leur entreprise le
cas échéant parce que ce n'est pas une
obligation ni pour le salarié d'ailleurs
ni pour le chef entre d'entreprises de
déférer à ses propositions pour objectif
et nous le partageons de favoriser la
sauvegarde des emplois car vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le ministre qui a plus
intérêt à la survie de l'entreprise que
les salariés eux-mêmes nous avons la
connaissons les chiffres nous y sont
d'ailleurs difficilement contestables
notre préoccupation et nous vous l'avons
nous avons eu l'occasion de vous le dire
c'est la sécurisation juridique du
dispositif proposé par ces articles
la notion d'intention de cession qui est
utilisée dans le texte pose de
véritables difficultés nous avons
cherché une formulation plus adéquate
plus sur juridiquement sans affaiblir le
dispositif proposé et nous avons tenté
ainsi de parvenir à formuler équilibré
confortant à la fois les objectifs
poursuivis par le gouvernement sans que
ces dispositions apparaissent
inapplicables ou extrêmement
contraignantes pour les chefs
d'entreprise car cette mesure ne sera
efficace que si elle est vue comme un
instrument facilitateur par les chefs
d'entreprise et non pas comme une
contrainte l'objectif c'est la survie
des entreprises le maintien des emplois
nos réflexions ont donc conduit à la
rédaction de cet amendement qui propose
de supprimer la notion d'intention de
cession ou d'intention de vendre et de
formuler plus simplement plus clairement
juridique dans les choses lorsque le
propriétaire d'un fonds de commerce le
céder les salariés en sont informés et
ce au plus tard de moi avant la session
cette formulation nous semble à la fois
conforter et sécuriser le dispositif
prévu à l'article 11 c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons de soutenir cet
amendement qu'on décline sur l'article
merci monsieur le président la
commission des lois souhaitent sous
amender Monsieur Mohamed soit
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
le présent amendement vient sous-amender
celui qui vient d'être présenté par
notre collègue Jacques Mezard
pour rendre plus lisible le champ
d'application du dispositif
d'information préalable des salariés en
cas d'intention de cession de fonds de
commerce dans les entreprises de 50 à
250 salariés en le mentionnant des le
premier article du code de commerce
il semble par ailleurs préférable
s'agissant de la mention de la catégorie
des PME de se référer à une disposition
de nature législative plutôt qu'à une
simple recommandation de la Commission
européenne sur le fond les critères sont
les mêmes dans ces deux textes
merci chers collègues l'amendement de
152 tombe le 90 Monsieur Le Cam
u très brièvement monsieur le Président
il s'agit d'augmenter le délai de deux
mois à trois mois
merci
l'amendement numéro 169 par les groupes
UC
mon intention était de réduire le délai
de deux mois à un mois car je pense dans
cette affaire plutôt que une information
sur l'intention de vendre c'est plutôt
une obligation pour le propriétaire de
l'entreprise de faire appel à
candidature au sein de l'entreprise je
pense que une fois qu'on a fait cet
appel à candidature il faut il vaut
mieux pas laisser l'entreprise dans un
dans une période d'immobilisme mais je
retire mon amendement et je soutiendrai
celui de Monsieur mesard qui me semble
aller dans le bon sens 169 retirer mais
c'est tant donné merci
111 rectifier quater
il est défendu vous l'avez défendu en
effet la commission des lois
l'amendement numéro 37 Monsieur Mohamed
salahi
oui lorsque le propriétaire du fonds de
commerce qui a l'intention de le céder
n'est pas l'exploitant il doit notifié
son intention à l'exploitant à recharge
pour lui dans l'informer son délai les
salariés le délai de deux mois avant
l'expiration duquel la session du fond
ne peut pas intervenir afin de laisser
au salarié intéressé la possibilité de
présenter une offre commence à compter
de la date de la notification à
l'exploitant
aussi le présent amendement propose dans
un souci de simplicité et de cohérence
du texte de prévoir que le délai de deux
mois en cas de notification directe aux
salariés coût à compter de la date de
cette notification
merci
le 254 rectifiés tombe 38 rectifiés
toujours un commission des lois monsieur
rapporteur oui c'est un amendement qui
vise à clarifier le fait que la décision
de ne pas présenter l'offre
de ne pas présenter d'offres appartient
à chaque salarié individuellement et
n'est pas une décision collective
merci
il y a sous amendement
du gouvernement
oui monsieur le Président le
sous amendement que nous proposons et de
supprimer selon les modalités précisées
par voie réglementaires
outre un aspect rédactionnel c'est un
sous un moment qui vise à supprimer
l'introduction par l'amendement 38 par
ailleurs bienvenue dans décret en effet
nous sommes pas opportuns d'imposer par
décret la façon dont les salariés pour
informer le Sedan de leur décision de ne
pas présenter l'offre merci
l'amendement 122
qui est le présente pour le groupe UMP
il est défendu
l'amendement 39 rectifié la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur en
remplacement
cet amendement tant à préciser que
l'action nullité de la cession du fonds
de commerce en cas de mes connaissances
de l'obligation d'information préalable
de salariés peut être engagé par tout
salarié et non pas par des salariés
comme cela était initialement précisé
une seconde précision
tant
à dire que le tribunal de commerce est
compétent pour connaître sauf qu'à
particulier des litiges nées à
l'occasion de la session d'un fonds de
commerce c'est la raison pour laquelle
il n'était pas utile de préciser que la
juridiction civile commerciale était
compétente
merci
amendement numéro 109
monsieur Retailleau
cet amendement vise à compléter cette
année-là en prévoyant une publication
dans un journal d'annonce légale pour
permettre une fixation précise
du point de départ de l'action en unité
par ailleurs l'obligation qui encombrait
au cédant être procédé bien sûr à une
information
sanctionner des fonds d'information par
la possibilité de la nullité de la
transaction paraît même d'ailleurs une
unité relative et pas seulement absolue
pareil dans tous les cas disproportionné
mais plus encore si les salariés ne
souhaitaient pas ou ne pouvaient pas se
porter acquéreur c'est pourquoi il
convient dans limiter la portée
merci Monsieur tantonnet un amendement
identique 173 oui mon amendement on va
dans le même sens pour donner quelques
garanties donc sur le point de départ de
l'action nullité et éviter les actions
nullité de pure opportunité car ça sera
peut-être toujours difficile de faire la
preuve de la notification de
l'information aux salariés donc je pense
que ces amendements pour être acceptés
ils garantirait les mesures de
transaction de cession d'entreprise
merci amendement numéro 160 Monsieur Le
Cam oui c'est amendement monsieur le
Président ce mini chers collègues vise à
renforcer l'information des salariés en
permettant de se faire assister par une
personne qui elle-même puisse se faire
communiquer les documents comptables et
être tenu à une obligation de discrétion
merci
162 toujours monsieur
renforcer l'accompagnement des salariés
notamment par les Chambres Consulaires
en lien avec les cresses merci
l'amendement numéro 40 de la commission
des lois sur un porteur
qui vise à garantir la sécurité
juridique de la phase d'information
préalable de salariés sur l'intention du
propriétaire du fonds de commerce de
vendre celui-ci grâce au recours à la
lettre recommandée avec avis de
réception ou à la lettre remise contre
récépissé de façon à limiter au maximum
le risque d'annulation contentieuse qui
pourrait résulter d'une information
imprécise ou incomplète le recours à la
lettre recommandée et d'ailleurs
fréquemment utilisé dans des
dispositions législatives cet amendement
vise également encadrer l'information de
l'exploitant du fonds de commerce chargé
de l'information des salariés lorsque
celui-ci n'est pas le propriétaire du
fond ce qui n'est actuellement pas prévu
par le texte merci monsieur le
rapporteur toujours le 41 s'il vous
plaît
oui un amendement qui vise à renforcer
l'obligation de discrétion des salariés
quant aux informations relatives à
l'intention de cession du fonds de
commerce les salariés devraient
toutefois être dédiés de cette
obligation de confidentialité à l'égard
des personnes qui peuvent les aider dans
les laboration de leur offre de rachat
de fonds sous le contrôle éventuel du
juge les professionnels auxquels il
serait fait appel serait en tout état de
cause soumis au secret professionnel les
concernant
merci
l'amendement 303 monsieur Denis selon la
Commission des Affaires économiques sous
amendement
oui il s'agit de remplacer les mots de
confidentialité par les modes discrétion
en effet le code du travail ne connaît
qu'une obligation de discrétion qui
s'applique aux informations qui revêtent
un caractère confidentiel il est donc
préférable dans la présente loi de se
référer à une notion bien connue dans la
loi savoir l'obligation de discrétion
plutôt qu'à une obligation de
confidentialité dont les contours et les
sanctions pourraient demeurer un certain
donc le présent sous amendement restaure
la rédaction de la Commission sur ce
point
merci l'amendement 167 monsieur tant
donné
mon amendement va dans le sens inverse
puisque je préférais l'expression
confidentialité qui me semblait plus
fort que la discrétion à la discrétion
c'est que ça ne pas des barrières la
confidentialité c'est ça me semble plus
fort mais s'il n'y a pas de référence
dans le code du travail peut-être que
je retire mon amendement
numéro 101 Monsieur Le Cam
et les retiré l'avendement numéro 94 il
est présenté oui monsieur le Président
c'est le ministère collègue c'est
amendement vise que en faire en sorte
que dans le cas de procédure de
sauvegarde de redressement ou de
liquidation judiciaire et salariés
puissent avoir droit de le faire une
offre et d'être en conséquence informée
par le juge
merci bien pour rester au micro pour le
92 oui l'amendement 92 reprend
l'engagement du président de la
République François Hollande d'inscrire
dans la loi un droit de préférence à
égalité d'offre bénéfice des salariés et
il précise donc la notion de priorité en
fonction d'un critère de localisation
des emplois de savoir-faire et des
maintiens des brevets dans le pays où le
territoire merci amendement 112 rectifié
quater monsieur Savary
le président monsieur le ministre cette
amendement simplement pour objectif en
droit de ligne de ce qu'on disait ce
matin de proposer des conditions
d'exemption au cas où le dirigeant de
l'entreprise aurait déjà trouvé un
repreneur ça me permet de répondre à
Monsieur le Ministre s'il veut bien
monsieur le ministre vous faisiez
allusion ce matin à une étude de BPCE
sur le chiffre des entreprises qui ne
trouvaient pas repreneur je me suis
amusé excusez-moi à rechercher cette
étude et je ne résiste pas à la
tentation de vous lire ce que dit
l'auteur de cette étude
la question puisque c'est une interview
qui est posée à cet auteur et la
suivante quel est votre avis sur
l'obligation d'information des salariés
avant toute sessions proposées telles
que c'est le cas de la du projet de loi
déposé par Monsieur Benoît à mon
pensez-vous que cela pourrait améliorer
les transmissions d'entreprises l'auteur
de l'étude BPCE dit j'avais cru
comprendre au départ que la volonté du
gouvernement était avec cette loi de
traiter le sujet des disparitions
d'entreprise non celui des sessions si
le problème est de s'attaquer aux
sociétés qui ne trouvent pas de
repreneur alors il me semble logique de
mettre en place un dispositif qui leur
soit spécifique or le projet de loi
actuel et notamment l'obligation
d'information des salariés deux mois
avant la session s'impose à elle à celle
où il y a précisément une reprise qui
est en train de se faire cela me paraît
paradoxal l'introduction d'un délai et
la diffusion d'une information aussi
configurant ce confidentielle à tous les
salariés peut fortement pénaliser la
relation qui aurait été construite avec
le repreneur de plus situer cette
annonce aussi près de l'échéance c'est
introduire en bout de chaîne risque
supplémentaire majeur que cette
opération n'aboutisse pas vous avez
compris pourquoi nous déposons cette
proposition d'amendement en discussion
merci merci chers collègues l'amendement
numéro 42 de la commission des lois
puis un moment de précision
rédactionnelle qui vise à inclure les
entreprises individuelles dans le
dispositif d'information préalable des
salariés
merci
l'amendement
113 rectifié quater monsieur Savary
dans les textes monsieur le Président de
reprendre cette notion de cessation
d'activités ça va tout à fait dans le
sens que de ce que vient dire mon
collègue André Richard à savoir que
cette notion de transmission éventuelle
à des salariés se posent lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de repreneur et non pas de façon
générale à chaque transmission
d'entreprise vous voyez que nous avons
des propositions bien précises dans ce
domaine là pour répondre à cette
préoccupation d'emplois qui
disparaissent comme vous l'avez présenté
monsieur le ministre
merci
l'amendement suivant numéro
43 de la commission des lois
oui j'ai eu l'occasion de donner des
explications tout à l'heure en
présentant le sous amendement 316 ce
sont les mêmes explications
merci
44 toujours
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
autant pour moi
c'est un
amendement pardon
visant à rétablir la cohérence du texte
et ménager dans les entreprises de 50 à
250 salariés un délai de deux mois à
compter de l'information des salariés
sur l'intention de cession du fond par
son propriétaire afin de leur permettre
s'il le souhaite de présenter une offre
de rachat à l'instar de ce que le texte
prévoit expressément dans les
entreprises d'au moins de 50 salariés à
l'état de la rédaction du texte les
salariés des entreprises d'au moins 50
salariés pourraient être quasiment privé
de fait de la possibilité de présenter
une offre de rachat le sel délai
implicitement prévu étant le délai de 15
jours laissé au comité d'entreprise en
application de l'article
l2323 du Code du travail pour se
prononcer sur un projet de cession
concomitamment à l'information des
salariés l'amendement procède un autre à
plusieurs coordinations de conséquences
s'agissant notamment de la concomitance
de l'information du comité d'entreprise
et de l'information des salariés
merci
d'abonnement 114 rectifié quaters de
Monsieur Savary
et du groupe
eux même au niveau de la linea 14 la
introduit la notion de cessation
d'activité
merci l'amendement 66 madame de montes
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le texte actuel de l'article 11
ne prévoit aucun délai pour
l'information préalable des salariés en
cas de cession d'un fonds de commerce
dans les entreprises employant entre 50
et 249 salariés c'est un amendement que
je vous présente et qui a été présenté à
la commission des affaires sociales
instaure en délai de deux mois en cas de
carence du comité d'entreprise
coïncidant avec une absence de délégué
du personnel en reprenant ainsi la règle
prévue dans les entreprises employant
moins de 50 salariés je vous rappelle
que 6% des établissements de plus de 50
salariés et de moins de 249 salariés ne
dispose nos disposait d'aucune
institution représentative du personnel
d'irp en 2010-2011 dans ces cas dans ces
cas on vous propose d'appliquer le délai
d'information prévu pour les entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés
l'abonnement numéro 45 la commission des
lois sur rapporteur
merci et à mon numéro 95 je me suis il
est défendu
bien monsieur Denise vous êtes prêts
vous avez 37 abonnements pour lesquels
on attend votre avis celui de la
Commission
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
et je
sollicite votre aide au cas où
éventuellement tel amendement tombé je
me laisserais aller à l'aborder je vais
commencer donc tout d'abord par le 3
rectifié bis avant de m'en retailler
cet amendement appliquer l'obligation
d'information dans un champ beaucoup
plus réduit que les articles 11 et 12
je suis un peu surpris parce que son
auteur que nous connaissons
particulièrement avertis
ne peut pas ignorer que d'une part
l'article
l1234,7 du Code de travail prévoit déjà
que la cessation de l'entreprise ne
libère pas l'employeur de l'obligation
de respecter le préavis il s'agit du
préavis habituel en cas de licenciement
donc pourquoi ajouter une formalité mon
chers collègues à un droit déjà existant
et qui serait satisfait surtout au
moment où on nous parle ensemble de
simplification administrative
d'autre part lorsque l'entreprise en
arrive à la radiation c'est bien souvent
que les possibilités de trouver un
repreneur ont été épuisés que la société
n'est plus véritablement viable il est
préférable d'instaurer en ce cas la
citation d'information dans le cas d'une
session du fonds de commerce comme le
propose l'article 11 ou d'une session
des par majoritaires dans l'entreprise
comme le prévoit l'article 12 et cet
amendement entre nous n'est plus un
amendement de repli c'est pardonne-moi
mais quasiment un faux nez un peu
grossier
par rapport au précédent amendement de
suppression et je suis un peu étonné que
connaissance en auteur et son expertise
il est plus céder à cela donc bien sûr
c'est un avis défavorable
nous prenons par contre les autres
amendements je permettais moi de faire
d'abord un chapeau luminaire
nous sommes partis d'un constat
50000 emplois détruits à partir de là un
refus de l'immobilisme
il y a là je pense une première approche
différente et le dispositif que nous
mettons en place
s'articule premièrement sur le 11a qui
dit droit d'information tout au long de
la vie de l'entreprise
regardons en amont pour inscrire presque
naturellement dans la vie de
l'entreprise
un tel rendez-vous si d'aventure il
venait à se présenter
deuxièmement
article 11 et 12 quand le propriétaire
veut céder c'est le sens de l'amendement
de notre collègue mes arts informations
des salariés au plus tard de moi avant
la session et c'est pour ça que j'aurais
plaisir de donner un avis favorable sur
l'amendement 265 troisième temps il faut
donner des meilleures garanties à la
fois en termes de
confidentialité
discrétion et à partir de là nous
bordons dispositif deuxièmement
en cas de volonté de reprise nous avons
l'amendement de notre collègue Le Cam
l'amendement 162 qui nous offre ainsi
une possibilité de donner le plus de
chances au dispositif qui nous le savons
tous
n'est pas une assurance touriste mais au
moins la première volonté de ne pas se
satisfaire un d'une conception archaïque
de l'entreprise deux de pouvoir
renforcer le droit des salariés 3
d'offrir enfin une alternative par
rapport aux 50000 emplois détruits voilà
la nature vraiment profonde de tout le
travail qui a été fait dans la
commission pour essayer de répondre
positivement à cela ce qui
mi avec permet d'aborder un deuxième
sujet nous avons envisagé le ministre la
reconnue lui-même d'aller jusqu'au droit
de préférence ou un droit de priorité
nous sommes vite aperçus que nous
générions faites plus de problèmes qui
risquaient de se retourner contre les
salariés en judiciarisant la procédure
c'est donc un dispositif pragmatique
équilibré qu'un souffle mais qui a aussi
une réalité concrète qui ainsi proposée
ce qui me conduit mes chers collègues au
nom de la Commission à vous proposer
pour l'amendement
je vais reprendre
que je viens de président Navy
défavorable retrait pour cet amendement
pour l'amendement 98
je parle du 3 rectifié
bon
en ce qui concerne l'amendement 98
cet amendement prévoit un dispositif
très complet d'autres amendements
reprendront le principe général par la
suite et adaptée donc je propose un
retrait sinon défavorable sur la demande
amendement avis défavorable
sur le 119 rectifié terre
idem défavorable
sur
qui est l'extension de l'obligation
d'information en cas de cessation
d'activité d'entreprise
il propose d'étendre l'obligation
d'information en cas de cessation
d'activité d'une entreprise en fait les
cessation d'activité pure et simple sont
rares car le chef d'entreprise s'aidera
plutôt sur notre entreprise à un prix
inférieur c'est ce qui a été dit par pas
ce qu'elle vaut donc assez peu de
possibilités dans ce cas donc je propose
un retrait et de toute façon cet
amendement n'est pas compatible avec
l'amendement 265 de notre collègue
mesard du président des arts donc je
propose un avis défavorable
265 donc rectifié bis avis favorable
concernant le 316 qui est un sous
amendement à l'amendement 265 il
clarifie le chant de l'article à savoir
les PME ce sous amendement reprend les
termes d'un amendement
qui risque de tomber si l'amendement de
165 est adopté et donc la commission a
donné un avis favorable qui s'applique
donc aussi à ce sous amendement c'est de
façon à pouvoir obtenir une coordination
entre les
les amendements
un moment 90 demandes-là je comprends
bien l'intention des auteurs de
l'amendement qui prévoit une extension
du délai plus
enfin plus long que dans l'amendement
précédent nous paraît préférable d'en
rester à cette rédaction qui est au plus
tard de moi sans figer un délai qui soit
différente de celui qui est proposé donc
je propose retrait ou défavorable
sans rectifier quoi de terre
retrait puisque c'est une conséquence de
l'abandance des mêmes auteurs donc
retrait ou défavorable naturellement en
ce qui concerne l'amendement de la
commission des lois le 37
favorable c'est un
sécurisation juridique du dispositif qui
nous apparaît opportun
le 38 rectifié toujours de notre
collègue enziani favorable
avec un
sous amendement présenté par le
gouvernement la Commission n'a pas pu
examiner ce sous amendement à titre
personnel je suis favorable car le
décret ne m'apparaît pas indispensable
l'amendement 122
avis défavorable puisque si l'on
supprime la sanction associée à une
règle de droit envie de bien souvent
cette règle de droit de sa substance
amendement 39 rectifié
à vie favorable
l'amendement 109
retrait ou défavorable parce que le
dispositif qui propose risquerait en
encourageant les entreprises à ne pas
impliquer l'obligation d'information à
multiplier les contentieux au lieu d'en
réduire le nombre ce qui m'apparaît
contraire à l'objectif de leurs auteurs
si on en reste à la lettre du de
l'amendement
amendement
60 je l'ai dit tout à l'heure avant de
retrait sinon défavorable en revanche au
bénéfice ce retrait de l'amendement 160
des mêmes auteurs pour lesquels la
commission a donné un avis
162 pardon la commission donnait un avis
favorable
en ce qui concerne l'amendement 40
la Commission souhaite
un retrait sinon elle serait défavorable
en ce qui concerne l'amendement 41
favorable avec le sous-amendement
présenté par le 303 concernant
confidentialité et
remplacement par discrétion droit du
travail
le 94
retraits ou défavorable car la
proposition de la proposition de loi
visant reconquérir l'économie réelle
prévoit ce type d'information et cela
paraît plus de se tordre et de ce
ressort là maintenant 92
retrait sinon défavorable on a déjà
expliqué pourquoi en ce qui concerne le
droit de préférence le 112 rectifié
quater
comme dit précédemment défavorable pour
une disposition qui rallongerait des
délais de cession puisque le cédant
déjà expliqué le 42 avis favorable
remplacent c'est un amendement de la
commission des lois proposant le
remplacement de société par entreprise
c'est pas plus juste
le 113 rectifié quater
retrait ou défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons que ce qui a été dit
précédemment pour leurs auteurs le 43
à vie favorable
le 44
si le 265 du président et d'adopter
il tombe si cela n'était pas le cas je
demanderai la Commission demande l'avis
du Gouvernement sur le 44 de la
commission des lois mais normalement si
le 265 est adopté il tombe
concernant le 114 rectifié quater cet
amendement est le dernier d'une série
d'amendements qui étonne l'obligation
d'information au cas de la session
d'activités comme pour le reste retrait
ou défavorable
amendement 66 de Madame de montes au don
de la commission des affaires sociales
cet amendement comme la vide et nous
remercions à nouveau le travail qui a
été effectué par chaque commission est
particulièrement
la commission des affaires sociales en
la matière
ça comme l'invite dans le cas où
l'information du comité d'entreprise ne
serait pas possible parce que celui-ci
ne possède pas d'élus donc c'est de la
vie favorable
l'amendement numéro 45 et un amendement
rédactionnel de clarification à vie
favorable l'amendement 95 en fin
comme pour l'amendement 94 je vous
propose mon chers collègues de vous
renvoyer vers la proposition de loi
visant à reconquérir l'économie réelle
et donc c'est plutôt
un retrait ou sinon défavorable
si monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
situation de pouvoir saisir
l'opportunité d'une offre des salariés
qu'elle soit la seule sur la table
qu'elle soit en concurrence avec
d'autres peu importe comme une offre à
part entière une offre ordinaire de
reprise de l'activité c'est la raison
pour laquelle à tous les dispositions ou
articles qui viseraient finalement je
suis d'accord avec le rapporteur a
supprimé en fait le droit d'information
pour les salariés dans l'hypothèse où il
pourrait être preneur je donnerai donc
un avis défavorable à ce 119 et à tous
les amendements qui
sont rapproche c'est le cas du trois
rectifié un mot sur le 98 il fait je
crois qu'il est il est en regard aussi
avec un autre amendement de Monsieur Le
Cam sur la question du droit prioritaire
droit de préférence
sujet sérieux d'abord ça existe c'est
vrai que on peut être prioritaire au
moment de racheter l'appartement dans
lequel on était locataire ça existe on
peut même dans un stand de cas regarder
en matière de cession de terrain
agricoles de parcelles de forêt il
existe des formes de droit prioritaire
après en mission bref mais il y a
toujours souvent une notion d'intérêt
général liée ou associée à ces droits là
que se passerait-il si nous créons à nos
yeux un droit de préférence aux
prioritaire il faudrait donc déterminer
des critères
ce qui amènerait probablement à
judiciariser considérablement la
transmission d'entreprise puisque ça
amènerait le juge à se saisir de
questions qui d'habitude sont
contractées par les parties prenantes
sans passer par la justice nous avons
aussi estimé que déterminer un ordre
prioritaire des salariés à offre égal
était posé des difficultés là encore sur
ce que pouvait être une offre égale en
toute circonstances
aussi sur ce point nous avons estimé que
ce droit prioritaire ou ce droit
préférentiel outre les obstacles
potentiels liés aux droits de propriété
à la liberté de commerce garantie par la
Constitution outre ces deux obstacles
qui ne sont quand même pas minces
horaires provoqué finalement une forme
de judiciarisation de la transmission
d'entreprise qui est assez éloigné de
l'objectif qui est de Le Nôtre je le
redis de d'allier
salariés et entreprises et chef
d'entreprise au moment de la
transmission quand il y a une difficulté
de reprise donc raison pour laquelle sur
ce 98 je donnerai je suggérerai le
retrait sinon à vie défavorable
le 117
de Madame La Mure qui supprime l'article
11 le droit d'information pour les
salariés bon avis défavorable là encore
à l'évidence je pareil sur le 119
rectifié j'en ai dit un mot tout à
l'heure sur le
110 qui prévoit l'information du salarié
avant la cessation d'activités là encore
il y a une différence entre la session
et la cessation d'activités c'est le but
c'est que quand il y a une transaction
au passage pour ceux qui
peuvent prétend absolument pas être
meilleur connaisseur de la transmission
mais
quand on cherche un repreneur quels sont
souvent les personnes les plus
intéressées à la reprise les concurrents
qui peuvent avoir intérêt ou à vous
affaiblir vous fermiez ou à vous
reprendre
et ce sont eux qui souvent quand ils se
font connaître qui ont l'information sur
le fait que vous cherchez à vendre qui
peuvent être parfois les plus intéressés
à faire savoir
que l'entreprise est à vendre pour
justement lui faire perdre de la valeur
et l'intérêt au passage de l'hypothèse
de salariés repreneurs c'est qu'elle
valorise l'entreprise aux yeux des
concurrents je m'explique c'est à dire
que si je suis seul sur un marché avec
un seul concurrent comme ça existe sur
des bassins d'emplois assez larges ou
sur même sur un département dans mon
concurrent qui peut être intéressé à ma
reprise peut être aussi intéressé à ma
reprise qu'à ma fermeture puisqu'il peut
penser récupérer mes clients par contre
s'il pense ou s'il sait que les salariés
de la dite entreprise qu'il pourrait
reprendre
peuvent formuler une offre il est en
face de lui cette fois-ci toujours un
concurrent ce qui valorise l'entreprise
qui pourrait être cédée et permet aux
cédant sans doute de céder un meilleur
prix à qui il veut à son concurrent ou à
ses salariés donc je veux donner aussi
cet argument pour pour sortir d'une
vision qui serait une vision peut-être
un peu trop
anxiogène de cette transmission même si
c'est toujours un moment angoissant pour
chef d'entreprise qui a peur de de
mettre la clé sous la porte sans vendre
et pour les salariés qu'on peut ordre de
rester sur le carreau le 265 rectifié de
Monsieur Mezard permettez-moi de m'y
arrêter quelques minutes
souligne que l'intention de céder c'est
flou et qu'il faut sans doute sécuriser
ce principe de façon à ce qu'on se
retrouve pas dans une situation où
finalement la lecture ou
l'interprétation de la loi serait
justement trop diffuse trop difficile à
saisir et je trouve que de ce point de
vue le fait de la rédaction qu'il
propose est intéressant parce qu'elle
sécurise le moment de déclencher le le
droit d'information et en précisant
qu'il se déclenche au plus tard deux
mois avant la session c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs parce que ça laisse libre le
chef d'entreprise de la déclencher
plutôt c'est-à-dire au plus tard de moi
ça peut être à trois mois deux mois et
demi comme bon lui semble essaie de ce
point de vue là une une démarche en tout
cas qui à mon sens
tourne le dos à toutes les formules qui
pourraient être tentés de dire on
déclenche le droit d'information quand
il y a pas entrepreneurs ont déclenché
notre formation le droit d'information
au moment de la cessation d'activité là
on la déclenche au moment où le chef
d'entreprise veut céder s'engage dans
une procédure dans laquelle il cherche à
un repreneur et avec en face de lui
potentiellement les salariés c'est la
raison pour laquelle par cette
amendement je crois de Monsieur je sais
même pas je crois je suis sûr de
Monsieur mesard Nous donnons plus de
clarté et donc de force à ce droit
nouveau et le gouvernement donnera un
avis favorable à l'amendement RDSE il
vous propose à sous amendement qui est
proposé par la Commission des lois et
par Monsieur soyez à l'instant
ils s'en remet à la sagesse de
l'Assemblée sur le 316 qui est proposé
pour sous amender le le le 265 sur le 38
de Monsieur
hanziani là encore sagesse sous réserve
d'un sous amendement qui a été déposé
par le le rapporteur je crois
et qui remplace la mention aux
propriétaires du fond par le cédant et
supprime le renvoi d'un décret pour sur
le 39 le Gouvernement est favorable au
39 tel qu'il a été réactifié sur le 37
le Gouvernement est favorable sur le 109
de Monsieur César et Madame Lamure qui
conditionne le recours du salariat à la
preuve qu'il a perdu une chance réelle
d'acheter l'entreprise ce qui je crois
rejoint l'amendement 173 de Monsieur
tant donné avis défavorable parce que
ces mesures et revient à nos yeux une
filière supprimer tout recours en
hybridité du salarié du fait de la
difficulté à prouver cette perte de
chance à chaque fois la charge de la
preuve et
imputable aux salariés en l'occurrence
je trouve que on a beaucoup encadré ce
droit d'information
on est dans des conditions ou
objectivement on prend tout le monde au
sérieux et on met tout le monde devant
ses responsabilités et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on met les salariés devant leur
responsabilité parce qu'ils vont
peut-être reprendre l'entreprise et que
on reprend pas une entreprise comme ça
du jour au lendemain au formulant une
offre sans avoir travaillé préparé d'où
l'importance des mesures
d'accompagnement qui peuvent être prises
et que l'article notamment
11a qui a été adopté et déjà voté permet
puisqu'elle permettra la formation sur
la transmission d'entreprise comme ça
parfois c'est deux trois cinq ans six
ans avant qu'on apprendra ou qu'on
connaîtra les conditions dans lesquelles
on peut reprendre l'entreprise donc
défavorable sur ces deux amendements sur
le 160 je vais donner et 162 de Monsieur
Le Cam sur le 160 à nos yeux cette je
vous proposerai le retrait si tu mesures
qui prévoit la possibilité pour les
salariés qui souhaitent faire une offre
d'achat de se faire assister par une
personne de leur choix cette personne
pouvant avoir accès aux informations qui
sont les informations détenues par le
chef d'entreprise sur la santé
économique financière de l'entreprise
nous pensons que là il y a une forme de
rupture d'égalité qui crée des facto une
priorité pour les salariés à travers
leur représentants à avoir accès à des
informations
confidentielles et qui nous semblent
rompre l'équilibre de la mesure telle
qu'elle a été pensée raison pour
laquelle je donnerai un avis défavorable
à cet amendement sur le 162 le
rapporteur a donné un avis je crois
favorable le gouvernement est plus
réservé
sur cette mesure
après en avoir discuté notamment
en réunion interministérielle nous avons
conclu que cette mesure qui prévoit la
possibilité pour les salariés qui
souhaitent faire une offre d'achat de se
faire assister par les services des
chambres consulaires
est une mesure qui n'est pas
indispensable c'est pour ça que je vous
proposerai volonté le retrait au sens où
à nos yeux il est il est déjà satisfait
et j'ai donc sur ce point un point de
vue différent du rapporteur qui lui est
favorable à cette amendement 162
sur le 40 retrait à nos yeux parce qu'il
est satisfait quand vous évoquez la
lettre recommandée avec accusé de
réception nous nous considérons que tout
moyen ça comprend la lettre recommandée
par accusé de réception donc nous
suggérons volontiers aux monsieur soyez
de la commission des lois si le souhait
s'il le veut évidemment si ça commission
le souhaite de retirer cette amendement
parce que nous la considérons le
considérons satisfait sur le
41 favorable sous réserve du Susanne de
sous-amendement
sous amendement qui a été là encore
déposée par le rapporteur c'est pas la
peine que j'insiste le 11 et le 95 j'y
vais direct les deux Monsieur Le Cam
c'est à nos yeux la PPL dite si rentable
ou économie réelle ou Florange ou elle a
été elle a eu beaucoup de noms cette PPL
et c'est pas en gros c'est pas le lieu
du texte SS pour
est-ce que c'est bien celui-là oui
oui voilà c'est ça pour pour adopter ces
mesures là donc
des retraits parce que
pas dans ce texte le 92 c'est un nouveau
la préférence un mot sur le 112 et la
BPCE
écoutez ce que dit le sénateur est
totalement exact mais moi je n'ai pas
prétendu que l'auteur de l'étude était
d'accord avec ma solution j'ai prétendu
que son diagnostic était bon genre pas
de chance monsieur tour du Mans de
Monsieur Pérolles d'une banque de
l'économie sociale BPCE qui se prononce
lors du meeting
d'ailleurs organisé par le MEDEF à Lyon
qui mettait un quart de ton jeune
au gouvernement se prononce contre ces
mesures bon ben voilà pas de chance que
ce salarié d'une banque de l'économie
sociale considère que dans la loi ESF
cette mesure n'est pas bonne mais il a
son opinion elles sont parfaitement
respectables et je voulais juste dire
que ce qui n'est pas en jeu c'est pas la
vie de Monsieur tour Duman c'est le
diagnostic qu'il fonde et nous nous
fournons sur le même diagnostic mais il
semble que nous ayons une approche
politique différente ou une réponse
politique différente parce que je crois
que c'est une approche politique
différente en ce qui nous concerne
en
l'espèce sur le 42 de Monsieur hanziani
défendu par Monsieur swahili favorable
sur le 113 rectifié ces sessions
d'activités donc défavorable
sur le 43
considérons qu'avec les amendements
l'amendement 265 de Monsieur Mazer qui
était modifié par le le 316 du
rapporteur il nous semble que cet
amendement n'est plus tout à fait
utile et donc nous suggérerons le
retrait sur le 44 je ne sais pas si il
tombe si le 65 est adopté mais
il nous considérons que nous nous avons
décidé de ne pas prévoir explicitement
le délai de deux mois pour les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés dès
lors que s'appliquera le délai préfixe
de consultation du comité d'entreprise
tel que prévu dans la nuit entre les
partenaires sociaux or ce délai suspend
en fait la session
disparaissait pas raisonnable de
rajouter un délai au délai c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons nous
proposons le retrait sur le on le 114
rectifié
prévoit le droit d'information là encore
lors de la session d'activité donc
défavorable favorable au 66 de Madame de
montest qui nous paraît comblé une
lacune trou dans la raquette comme on
dit de la rédaction initiale du
gouvernement favorable au 45 de la
commission des lois et enfin j'en
termine par le maintenant le 95 Monsieur
Le Cam je suis déjà exprimé dessus
alors que oui mais on s'est compris tout
à l'heure et donc
défavorable parce que ou retrait
retrait au défavorable monsieur le
Président et sur le sens également
d'accord
bien madame n'est favorable
madame Goulet
49 83 de notre règlement je suis
absolument désolé mais pour les
sénateurs qui n'appartiennent pas à la
commission des affaires économiques et
qui voudrait quand même suivre ce texte
important dont on voit que c'est un
texte sur les principes j'ai beaucoup de
difficultés à suivre quand 37 ou 38
amendements sont des battus en même
temps alors je sais bien que les
services de la séance font le maximum je
sais bien que nous sommes tous très
attentifs mais je voulais quand même
souligner la très grande difficulté sur
un texte qui a quand même des options et
sur lesquelles on peut discuter de
travailler dans des conditions pareilles
c'est pas tout à fait la première fois
que c'est arrivé puisque dans un texte
précédent on a eu pratiquement une
centaine d'amendements à débattre en
discussion commune et je pense qu'il
faudrait un moment ou un entre dans
cette maison qu'on arrive à trouver une
solution de façon à ce que les gens qui
comme moi appartiennent à la commission
des affaires étrangères la commission
des finances ou à d'autres commissions
Mexiques qui sont quand même intéressés
par ce texte puisse débattre des
amendements dans des conditions
satisfaisantes je vous remercie monsieur
le Président merci chers collègues de
votre appel règlement monsieur
Retailleau rappeller règlement oui mais
simplement pour approuver ce que dit
notre collègue il y a pas besoin
d'ailleurs de séparer ceux qui sont de
la commission d'économie des autres
commissions je pense que dans dans
l'ensemble des amendements qu'on a
étudié il y avait vraiment plusieurs
angles différents et je crois que la
qualité de notre travail aurait pu
gagner à essayer au moins sur des angles
qui pouvaient être communs regrouper les
amendements mais sans faire un
regroupement absolument systématique et
je pense que voilà pour encore une fois
la qualité de nos travaux il faut
peut-être y penser pour les fois
prochaine
bien le président de la commission vous
a écouté attentivement nous allons
passer donc au vote de chacun de ces
amendements et je rappelle que chacun
peut s'exprimer sur ces différents c'est
un rappel au règlement madame
alors je précise bien que nous allons
commencer par voter le 3 rectifier bis
et c'est sur cet amendement que vous
demandez pas la parole sur celui-ci donc
sur cet amendement rectifié avis
défavorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 98
il est retiré
l'amendement numéro 117
avait défavorable du gouvernement avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté 119
rectifier terre avis défavorable à
commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement même vote même vote
amendement 110 rectifié quater avec
défavorable commissions à véritablement
même vote même vote
265 rectifiés bis avis favorable de la
commission alors pardon je fais c'est
vous demander la parole sur cette
amendement
donc je remettrai aux voix d'abord le
sous amendement mais vous exprimez
notre collègue mes arts et le groupe RDS
de sa contribution à la clarification
d'une notion qui si elle était restée
floue risquait justement de fragiliser
le dispositif nous partageons avec son
groupe le groupe socialiste nous a mis
du groupe
écologiste et du groupe communiste la
volonté que cette affaire fonctionne
bien dans la sérénité et la sérénité
suppose que le cadre juridique soit
sécurisé donc je voudrais le remercier
de sa contribution à la définition de
quand commence la mécanisme
d'information des salariés par ailleurs
je voudrais dire quelques mots sur
l'argument qui nous a été donné selon
lequel seul au moment où la session
aurait déjà lieu il n'y aurait pas de
repreneur il faudrait engager la
procédure au-delà des remarques
juridiques qui ont été forte
opportunément développées par notre
rapporteur et par le gouvernement je
voudrais dire quand même qu'il arrive
parfois et moi il se trouve que je suis
d'une famille où on a une petite
entreprise de bâtiments de mon
grand-père etc
quand les personnes commencent à
vieillir elles n'ont pas toujours
l'éclairage suffisant par rapport à la
qualité du repreneur alors certes ils
peuvent trouver des conseils pour les
pour les accompagner mais quand vous
informer les salariés il peut vous aussi
eux-mêmes donner leur
un conseil mais un éclairage à au chef
d'entreprise sur la viabilité le sérieux
que eux salariés peuvent avoir quant à
cette reprise ça n'enlève rien aux
qualités d'arbitrage final du
propriétaire mais le salarié peut être
un bon un bon comment dire avoir un
regard plus aiguisé parfois que le chef
d'entreprise qui avec le temps ne voit
pas toujours les mauvais coups ce
profiler à l'horizon
si chers collègues je vais mettre donc
on voit le sous amendement
316 après que Madame bataille se soit
exprimé
vous remercie monsieur le Président je
veux dans le droit fil de ce que vient
de dire Madame linman et Monsieur le
Ministre la fort bien rappelée depuis la
discussion générale hier monsieur le
rapporteur aussi également que ce droit
d'information des salariés avant tout
projet de cession est un droit nouveau
qui s'intègre d'ailleurs parfaitement
dans les dispositions que la gauche a
fait voter dès 82 sous l'égide de Jean
Auroux dont je veux rappeler qui
l'assistait à nos travaux hier dans les
tribunes pour montrer son attachement à
cette filiation des dispositions qui ont
passablement marqué les esprits je me
tourne vers les bancs du groupe CRC
Monsieur Le Cam comme comme ses
collègues s'en souviennent encore
aujourd'hui c'est un droit nouveau dans
un contexte économique difficile aux
conséquences dramatiques pour l'emploi
dans nos territoires et c'est aussi un
droit nouveau pour les salariés des PME
qui sont bien souvent tenus à l'écart
des décisions relatives à la
l'entreprise faute d'institutions
représentative alors certes dans de
nombreuses PME ça a été rappelé la
proximité est forte entre le patron et
ses salariés et on peut envisager que la
pérennité de l'entreprise puisse faire
l'objet des changements et transparents
entre le patron et ses salariés
cependant la proximité ne constitue pas
un droit et seul le droit peut permettre
aux intérêts des partis prenantes de
l'entreprise de s'exprimer alors ce
matin j'ai eu un échange avec Monsieur
Dallier je crois que il avait mal
interprété nos propos il ne s'agissait
pas d'opposer création d'emplois et
bénéfices mais simplement insister sur
l'idée qu'une entreprise ne peut pas se
concentrer sur le seul profit mais que
l'emploi est au moins aussi important et
lorsque l'emploi est en jeu il n'est pas
extravag que les salariés puissent avoir
une chance de s'engager dans sa
préservation notamment lorsqu'il s'agit
de leur emploi on ne peut pas faire je
crois sur vos bancs à l'UMP de procès
quant aux intentions du Gouvernement et
à sa volonté de tout tenter pour
combattre le chômage alors je veux
souligner le fait que le gouvernement
est mis dans le débat politique le sujet
de la reprise d'entreprise par leur
salarié on sait désormais que les
transmissions ratées font perdre un
nombre d'emplois conséquents 50 000 ça a
été rappelé depuis hier à l'instant par
Madame de montes et Madame linmann et je
crois que personne à droite ne peut
prétendre sérieusement qu'un droit
nouveau aurait des conséquences
négatives sur l'emploi donc le
gouvernement a voulu un délai de deux
mois pour informer les salariés en cas
de cession d'une entreprise
information qui serait obligatoire dans
toute entreprise de moins de 250
salariés ce délai est conforté par
l'amendement de Monsieur Mezard et
demeure le dispositif pivot du droit
d'information des salariés
merci chers collègues s'il n'y a pas
d'autres explications de vote je mets
aux voix le sous amendement 316 avait
favorable de la commission à vie de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est
favorable
contre
abstention il est adopté je mets aux
voix maintenant l'amendement 265
rectifié Beast du Président mes arcs qui
est pour
contre
il est adopté
ainsi le 90 tombe
d'accord le sens également
et nous en sommes au 37
pour lequel nous avons un avis favorable
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est le Président j'ai pas bien suivi
le vote et je demande que vous
confirmation il me semblait que sur
l'amendement 265 l'UMP s'était abstenu
est-ce que j'ai bien compris où j'ai mal
compris
non nous n'avons pas pris par votre
d'accord
merci
donc si tout le monde est d'accord nous
en arrivons à l'amendement numéro 37 sur
l'amendement 37 avis favorable de la
commission avis favorable du
gouvernement par l'explication de vote
qui est pour
contre
abstention il est adopté
je vais mettre voir ensuite le sous
amendement
qui est favorable
qui est
est
la commission
la vie alors l'amendement 284
monsieur le rapporteur j'ai noté un avis
favorable de la commission
nous sommes d'accord
favorables du gouvernement oui bien sûr
donc avis favorable voilà donc nous
sommes d'accord amendement 280
sous-amendement
qui est favorable
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté je mets maintenant au voie
l'amendement 38 rectifier pour
contre
abstention adopter nous sommes sur
l'amendement maintenant 122 à vie
défavorable des du gouvernement et de la
commission pour
contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 39 rectifié de la
commission des lois
pour
contre
abstention il est adopté
l'amendement 109
avis défavorable demande de retrait
commission gouvernement pour
contre
abstention adoptée
retirez
l'amendement 162
maintenu qui est pour la vie favorable
de la commission
pour
contre
abstention il est adopté
monsieur le président
je pense que c'est un problème de
d'audition qu'on peut avoir dans
l'hémicycle sur le 109 il est bien clair
qu'il n'est pas adopté c'est dans votre
je sais pas comment vous l'avez formulé
mais on a un doute
j'adopter cher président Raoul merci
monsieur
je vous prie de m'excuser
j'articule dans
si nous avons bien compris nous sommes
maintenant aux 40
avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement
qui est favorable
qui j'ai lancé le vote je vais au bout
du vote qui est favorable
pardon vous voulez le retirer
je suspends le vote prenez la parole
monsieur le rapporteur pour nous
éclairer
merci monsieur le Président d'abord pour
préciser que la commission des affaires
économiques avait demandé le retrait
et je comptais intervenir pour dire que
j'étais peiné parce que je ne retirais
pas l'amendement puisque je ne fais que
modestement substitué notre collègue
allait à Ziani et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il aurait retiré cet amendement
puisqu'il poursuit des buts de sécurité
juridique et de meilleures informations
des salariés
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit que
cet amendement a été satisfait parce que
en disant par tout moyen forcément
cela comprend recommandé
et la remise contre récépissé mais cela
peut aussi ne pas comprendre le
recommandé et la remise contre récépissé
moi je pense que cet amendement poursuit
un but
de sécurisation et en plus ajoute de la
souplesse en prévoyant la forme de
récépissé de remise contre récépissé il
a été énormément débattu au sein de la
commission des lois qui a
qu'il a ainsi adopté donc je ne le
retirais pas
bien alors nous allons mettre monsieur
le rapporteur de la commission faire
économique
dans l'alinéa en question il est dit
l'information des salariés peut être
effectué par tout moyen virgule précisé
par voie règlementaire virgule de nature
à rendre certaines la date de réception
par ces derniers il nous apparaît que à
la fois le tout moyen dans la loi et
préciser par voie règlementaire
couvre au combien largement le champ qui
est censé être concerné
de plus prendre un moyen d'information
alors qu'on est sur tout moyen
nécessiterait soit de faire une liste
la plus exhaustive possible et donc
alourdir la loi soit alors d'un exclure
d'autres donc tout ce que nous proposons
donc le retrait sinon défavorable avec
tout le respect que nous avons pour le
travail de la commission des lois qui
par ailleurs a été particulièrement
importante pour nos travaux bien donc
demande renouveler de retrait j'imagine
renouvellement du maintien donc nous en
sommes au point où nous allons mettre au
foie cet amendement 40 avec donc un
amendement proposé par la Commission des
lois avec un avis défavorable de la
commission de vie économique et un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas adopté
je mets au voie la sous amendement 303
avec avis favorable de la commission et
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre et que ça tient il est
adopté
et donc je mets aux voix l'amendement
numéro 41 qui a un avis favorable
puisque le sous-amendement est adapté
qui est pour
contre
abstention
ils sont adoptés
le
94 avec un avis défavorable qui est pour
retirer
le 92 également et le 95 le sera un peu
plus tard
le 112 rectifié à vie défavorable pour
contre
adopter un
abstention je voulais dire
il n'est pas adopté le 42 de la
commission des lois avis favorable
gouvernement et commission pour
contre abstention adoptée le 113
rectifié quater même vote
même vote
113 rectifié avis défavorable de la
commission avis défavorable
bon
qui est pour
contre
abstention je n'en vois pas
le 43 le 44 tombe
le 114 rectifié
pardon monsieur
le président en temps je comprends que
le 44 tombe mais pour le 43 j'aimerais
en être bien sûr alors regardez
nous sommes d'accord
le 114 monsieur le rapporteur à mon avis
tombe également vous êtes d'accord
d'accord l'amendement
66 de Madame de montes avis favorable de
la commission avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
contre abstention et il est adopté et
l'amendement 45
avis favorable le gouvernement et
commission pour
contre abstention adoptée sur l'article
demande d'explication de vote avant que
je le mette au bois monsieur Retailleau
une explication de vote pour clarifier
notre position et reprendre un certain
nombre de points qu'on a déjà abordés au
fil de la défense de ces amendements
encore une fois il s'agit pas d'opposer
ceux qui voudraient une transmission
fluide une autre une transmission qui ne
le serait pas je pense que la ligne de
partage elle est politique vous avez eu
raison monsieur le ministre vous avez
assumé vous avez indiqué tout à l'heure
que il y a une différence politique vous
avez d'ailleurs cité ou des faits
référence au général de Gaulle je suis
pas sûr que sur ce texte il lui fallut
insister sur cette référence là je pense
que celle de Monsieur prudent aurait
peut-être été plus adapté plus
globalement mais ce qui nous oppose en
fait c'est de vision très différentes
une vision que vous portez que vous
soutenez c'est votre droit qui est le
systématisme et une autre vision qui
pour nous le pragmatisme nous voulons
tous nous voulons tous faciliter et
encourager les transmissions mais nous
pensons que le dispositif que vous êtes
en train de créer va entraver à
compliquer va gêner les transmissions
pour plusieurs raisons la première
raison nous y sommes déjà revenu un
certain nombre de fois je ferai court la
sécurité juridique vous allez créer avec
ce nouveau texte ce nouveau dispositif
des sources nouvelles de contentieux
bien sûr ne vous direz sans doute qu'il
s'agit pas de nullité absolue etc
facultative bien sûr mais vous vous
trouverez dans des cas nécessairement ou
une transmission aboutie une transaction
finalisée sera remise en question que se
passera-t-il pour des raisons de forme
du coup pour des raisons de forme
insécurité juridique l'autre question
c'est le problème de la complexité Marc
donniste malicieusement tout à l'heure
m'a fait remarquer que on voulait tous
un grand choc de simplification que
faites-vous vous ajoutez des pages et
des pages à nos codes qui dans le monde
entier sont sans doute déjà les codes
les plus épais est-ce qu'on épaississant
les codes on va simplifier
et on va fluidifier fluidifier le
processus de transmission certainement
pas vous créez de nouveaux seuils mes
chers collègues nouveau seuil pour 5 ans
nouveau seuil entre 50 et 25 0 si il y
aura des règles nouvelles bien entendu
et il faut le souligner je vous citais
l'autre jour Monsieur le Ministre
Bossuet en commission vous chérissez les
causes et vous déplorez les effets c'est
exactement ça tout le monde comme des
cabris sautent sur sa chaise pour dire
simplifiant simplifions simplifiant et
on passe notre temps ajoutez des règles
ajouter des nouvelles contraintes
la troisième raison c'est que
la confidentialité
c'est un point qui est important parce
que le processus de transmission est
toujours un processus fragile
susciter une inquiétude vis-à-vis par
exemple des fournisseurs vis-à-vis des
financeurs des banquiers vis-à-vis des
clients ça ne peut conduire ça ne peut
conduire qu'à complexifier mais surtout
ça ne peut conduire que à gêner ce
processus précisément de transmission
des entreprises j'ai entendu dans les
arguments que comment l'UMP le centre
serait pas confiance aux salariés ça
n'est pas ça du tout je citais tout à
l'heure une réunion nous étions une
vingtaine seulement avec des cabinets
des deux ministres pour parler de Fagor
fagorky d'ailleurs entre nous est une
filiale d'une grande coopérative la plus
grande coopérative mondiale
qui s'est pas comporté bien avec son
entreprise sa filiale française preuve
que la vertu n'est pas nécessairement
d'un côté et le vice de l'autre
bien entendu bien entendu en revanche ce
que je veux indiquer par là c'est que
qu'est-ce que les cabinets nous ont
indiqué quand on les questionnait quand
on a appris qu'il y aurait peut-être
des pistes de reprise on nous a objecté
la confidentialité nous étions des élus
président de Région président de
départements parlementaire et on nous a
dit levez le voir sur les intentions ce
serait une façon de les tuer donc vous
voyez et on en a pas été étonné on a
reçu cet argument de convivialité on
sait pas de draper dans de dignité
d'élus pour dire on veut immédiatement
le nom des repreneurs pour telle et tel
site de fagorbant en France donc
lorsqu'on objecte le problème de
confidentialité vis-à-vis des salariés
ça n'est pas pour rabaisser les salariés
pas plus que je me sens rabaissé comme
élu quand on object à moi le problème de
la confidentialité pour conclure pour
conclure je pense que c'est une mauvaise
façon de légiférer
beaucoup beaucoup de transmissions se
passent bien et vous légiférer à partir
de quelques cas qui sont des cas
effectivement limites mais vous créez
les contraintes pour tous pour tous et
vous risquez de créer des entraves pour
tous pour toutes les transmissions c'est
une mauvaise façon de légiférer vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
que les cinq organisations
représentatives des salariés étaient
pour vous avez dit ça compte je pourrais
vous dire les cinq organisations
représentatives des chefs d'entreprise
son compte il vous a envoyé un courrier
qu'ils ont signé il n'y a plus que trois
dans le courrier qu'on m'a qu'on m'a
donné ça compte aussi mais ça n'est pas
l'argument d'iriment ce que je pense
pour reprendre d'ailleurs une phrase qui
n'est pas de moi qui le titre d'un
article est paru dans le monde il y a
quelques jours de fleurs pèlerin
ce titre c'était nous avons une vision
trop idéologique de l'entreprise je
pense que vous avez une vision
idéologique et décalée de l'entreprise
parce qu'avec ce texte vous pouvez faire
croire que finalement l'échelle
d'entreprise on doit pouvoir les
suspecter qui peut y avoir une défiance
parce qu'il refuse de dialoguer sur tous
les moins de 50 quand on connaît les
réalités absolument pas le cas il refuse
de dialoguer de donner de l'information
à leurs salariés ils ne connaissent pas
leurs salariés ils ne connaissent pas
ceux de se leur salarié qui pourrait
reprendre alors que je vous assure pour
en connaître de nombreux que leur
premier mouvement quand il y a un
phénomène de reprise c'est vers
l'intérieur c'est vers les salariés
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu'il ne faut pas faire porter ce
mouvement défiance vis-à-vis des chefs
d'entreprise de suspicion on y gagne
jamais et je pense que le gouvernement
justement dans ces zigzags donne des
signaux trop contradictoires tant en
voulant tantôt voulant encourager les
chefs d'entreprise la compétitivité est
tantôt
donnant justement des signes d'une
défiance et c'est la raison pour
laquelle bien sûr nous ne voterons pas
cet article merci chers collègues
monsieur Savary
pour compléter s'il le fallait brillante
intervention de mon collègue
Retailleau simplement il y a un vrai
problème de sémantique qui nous sépare
et qui est l'expression véritablement de
deux philosophies différentes à travers
les amendements il y a eu un peu de
progrès d'intention passe à volonté
c'est l'amendement de Monsieur mesard et
qui est effectivement déjà un peu plus
percutant à travers à travers le
dispositif mais qui ne nous suffit pas
compte tenu de ce que nous pensons et
que je vais vous vous exposer ensuite
autre problème de sémantique différence
entre discrétion et confidentialité bah
ouais mais il y a quand même une vraie
un vrai problème moi je confirme ce que
dit mon collègue Retailleau quand on est
à discuter
au niveau des des entreprises en
difficulté ou en reprise d'activité on
nous demande toujours une
confidentialité tout à fait nécessaire
je vous dirai même que j'ai la triste
expérience actuellement d'une reprise de
mon délégataire de service public
excusez-moi
je disais oui bien sûr je sais bien
je disais que j'avais une expérience là
tout à fait
concrète de reprise d'action par mon
dégâts légataire de de service public en
ce qui se concerne la gestion de
l'aéroport du département de de la Marne
et il y avait derrière un nouvel
actionnaire qui était prêt à entrer dans
le capital de cette société il y a eu
des fuites c'est paru sur les journaux
qui allaient avoir une une reprise et
derrière il s'est retiré il s'est retiré
parce que c'était contre-productif par
rapport à sa stratégie il fallait rester
dans la confidentialité pour vis-à-vis
de ces banques notamment faire en sorte
de ne pas exposer directement des
actions parallèles à d'autres qu'ils
souhaitaient mener donc on voit bien que
là aussi on peut mettre des entreprises
en difficulté
et puis la dernière
sémantique
que l'on peut traduire à travers notre
débat c'est la différence qu'on a déjà
exprimée entre transmission et
disparition oui en cas de disparition
des activités d'une entreprise il est
important que les salariés qui est un
dispositif en tout cas qui oblige de
d'informer les salariés avec un certain
nombre de mesures sia cessation
d'activité mais il ne faut pas
généraliser le dispositif à l'ensemble
des transmissions c'est quand même clair
c'est pas à dispositif généralisé à
l'ensemble des transmissions qui vous
fera obtenir des résultats sur une
contrainte supplémentaire dans le cas où
il y a pas de reprise dans le cas où il
y a pas de reprise et donc on se tourne
vers une session c'est là qu'il faut
mettre sur pied à dispositif mais pas
dans chaque transmission systématique
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voterons contre certains articles 11
merci Monsieur guerriot à la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le droit
d'information des salariés en cas de
transmission d'une entreprise saine
porte finalement un objectif louable
puisque il s'agit de tenter de préserver
l'emploi l'activité et en cela nous
pouvons être que d'accord et si
effectivement cet article nous apportait
toute confiance et permettait de nous
assurer que nous arrêtons un tendrillon
ce type de résultat nous pourrions que
le voter le problème c'est que les
contours que vous proposez sont source
de confusion le projet de loi ne prévoit
d'ailleurs pas le risque de voir une
offre d'achat présentée à la seule fin
de retarder la session le délai
d'information de deux mois créé en
réalité une période d'incertitude tant
sur le plan juridique économique puisque
aujourd'hui extrêmement difficile d'en
mesurer les conséquences puisque nous
sommes incapables de pouvoir déterminer
les risques que nous encourons avec
l'application de la terre arctique je
dirais qu'il faut en appeler au principe
de précaution et ne pas le voter
merci la parole est au président Raoul
simplement je voudrais effectivement au
bout de cette discussion très longue sur
l'article 11 considérez que c'est une
avancée remarquable pour un certain
nombre de millions de salariés il y a
pas simplement ceux qui sont en dessous
de 50 salariés l'amendement de Madame de
montest ouvre aussi des nouvelles
horizon entre ceux qui sont entre 50 et
249 salariés ça doit représenter plus de
8 millions de salariés je crois que
c'est une avancée remarquable au niveau
des droits des salariés je voudrais dire
notre collègue qui parle de défiance
vis-à-vis des patrons d'entreprises
c'est au contraire un message de
confiance et d'encouragement vis-à-vis
des salariés alors chacun peut voir midi
à sa porte mais en tous les cas c'est
dans ce sens là que je considère
l'article 11
ch chaque collègue plus de demandes de
parole sur l'article 11 que je vais donc
mettre au voir si monsieur le rapporteur
ça va être très vrai puisque beaucoup
d'échanges ont eu lieu et je pense de
qualité je dirais simplement notre
collègue Retailleau que là où il voit
systématisme contre pragmatisme je pense
qu'il fait fausse route en l'occurrence
et
quand n'est pas justement sur du
systématisme mais on est sur du réalisme
de la lucidité par rapport à une
situation qui existe vous ne pouvez pas
vous abstrait surtout vous
qu'il y a aujourd'hui 50000 emplois
détruits vous pourrez prendre le
problème par tous les sens la force la
violence de ce chiffre demeure après
deuxièmement ne soyons jamais
caricaturaux bien sûr que telle ou tel
exemple peut être pris
il s'agit pas ici de dire qu'il y aurait
une économie qui serait en tous les cas
en toute circonstances en tout lieu et
en toute situation
vertueuse quand une autre pardonnez-moi
non ça les uns et les autres
heureusement heureusement ne nous
situons pas dans un tel contexte par
contre
ce qu'il y a qui est très clair c'est
que vous avez une conception
pardonnez-moi mais que je n'arrive pas à
saisir et si je reprenais la
simplification que vous avez fait tout à
l'heure je serai tenté de dire qu'il y a
deux côtés une conception
ancienne un peu archaïque presque
frileuse de l'entreprise de
l'entreprenariat par rapport à une
évolution dans un monde qui change cette
ce sentiment que la valeur profonde
d'une entreprise ça peut être certes le
talent de telle ou telle manager ça peut
être la qualité d'un marché mais la
première richesse d'une entreprise
demeurera la valeur de ces salariés et
la valeur elle est justement et la
valeur de ces producteurs et à partir de
là
en reprenant les différents éléments
est-ce que le fait qu'on puisse leur
permettre d'exprimer encore mieux ses
talents de pouvoir faire que dans des
situations ou dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés là où pour des
raisons objectives la transmission ne
peut pas
forcément être envisagé anticiper
parfois arrive dans des conditions qui
sont presque subies
et justement justement le fait d'avoir
inscrit à l'article 11
la possibilité qu'il est cette
information tout au long de la vie va
faire que ce pourquoi vous êtes frileux
aujourd'hui vous avez même employé les
termes d'anxiogènes va s'inscrire dans
la vie de l'entreprise et derrière à
travers ce renforcement des droits des
salariés nous permettent de consolider
particulièrement je pense aux rurales
mais consolider beaucoup de économie de
maillage local économique précieux
c'est monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
oui mais je vais être très bref puisque
les social des arguments ont été
échangés sur ces bancs
pourquoi je me réjouis
si cette article 11 était adoptée
dans quelques minutes d'abord parce que
dans une société où bon nombre de nos
compatriotes à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise ou à l'extérieur de
l'entreprise le sentiment d'avoir perdu
le pouvoir et le pouvoir de maîtriser
leur vie ce droit d'information donne
incontestablement du pouvoir
et c'est en soi et ça me réjouit
d'ailleurs
une belle chose et je le dis comme un
ministre d'un gouvernement de gauche que
la gauche sera rassemble pour donner un
pouvoir supplémentaire au salarié et
qu'elle soit une nouvelle fois au
rendez-vous du progrès social je vous
renverrai je trouve
cette citation tellement conforme à ce
qu'est l'idée de l'ESS un des très
anciens économistes philosophes aussi un
des pères d'une des premières théories
de la monnaie Jean Bodin il disait que
il n'était de richesse que d'hommes vous
la connaissez et bien je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on se préoccupe dans
l'entreprise des hommes mais en même
temps sans se désintéresser de
l'activité économique elle-même et en
permettant que l'entreprise personne
morale subsiste à un départ du chef de
l'entreprise par le fait que les
salariés disposent et d'un droit et la
possibilité de reprise je pense que nous
sommes au rendez-vous du progrès social
et je me réjouis que ce message soit
adressé en y associer un message de
confiance à l'égard des entreprises donc
je me réjouis de ce rassemblement de la
gauche en faveur de ce nouveau droit
pour les salariés en France
merci monsieur le ministre je vais donc
on voit cet article 11 il n'y a plus de
demandes de parole je mets the wake pour
contre
abstention
l'article 11 est adopté
vous l'avez vu les sénateurs ont donc
adopté cet article 11 relatif à la
formation préalable des salariés en cas
de cession de l'entreprise afin de
favoriser la reprise de cette entreprise
par ces mêmes salariés quelques heures
plus tard les sénateurs ont également
adopté l'ensemble du texte c'est ce
moment que je vous propose de voir à
présent
monsieur le rapporteur mais chers
collègues je suis donc le port de parole
du groupe
UMP comme mes collègues Elisabeth Lamur
et gérard César l'avaient annoncé en
discussion en général deux dispositions
de ce projet de loi ont retenu notre
attention
au nom de mon groupe dont nous ne ferons
nous ferons l'impasse sur les
dispositions du titre 3 à 8 sur la
modernisation du régime des coopératives
les associations les fondations ou les
sociétés d'assurance qui pour beaucoup
d'entre elles rencontrent d'ailleurs
notre adhésion
nous ne nous attacherons pas non plus
sur l'article 9 et sur la création d'un
schéma de promotion des achats publiques
socialement responsables et donc sur la
création des clauses édites sociales
dans les contrats nouvelle procédures
qui nous apparaissent comme de nouvelles
charts administratives disproportionnées
par rapport au bénéfice escomptés alors
notre critique car il y en a quand même
notre critique du projet de loi portera
donc sur deux points la détermination du
champ de l'ESS à leur type premier qui
permet notre l'obtention de l'agrément
entreprise solidaire l'article 7 et bien
sûr l'information anticipée des salariés
pour leur permettre de formuler une
offre de rachat
pour la détermination du champ de
l'économie sociale et solidaire vous
avez fait le choix d'un dispositif
restrictif qui élimine la plupart des
sociétés commerciales nous ne
reviendrons pas sur la démonstration de
nos collègues la rédaction des articles
premiers 7 ne laissant que peu de doute
sur la place des entreprises dans le SS
alors aussi face à l'entêtement du
gouvernement nous avons essayé
d'entrevoir le raisonnement qui a
conduit à la rédaction de cet article et
à l'exclusion des sociétés commerciales
pour beaucoup le développement
d'entreprise abusent lucratif dans le
secteur des services à la personne en
concurrence avec les associations
participe à une sorte disons décrémage
de la partie la plus rentable de ce
marché limitant ainsi la politique de
mutualisation permettant d'offrir des
services de qualité à des personnes ne
disposant pas de moyens suffisants alors
chacun peut comprendre ce raisonnement
les entreprises commerciales se portent
en effet prioritairement vers les
secteurs permettant les taux de
rentabilité plus élevés et aussi on peut
faire deux remarques pourquoi empêcher
le développement des entreprises
commerciales vers ces secteurs pourquoi
exclure le privé de ce qui est rentable
c'est un parti pris pour le moins
étrange seconde remarque lorsque l'offre
de service à la personne arrive à
saturation en ce qui concerne les
services les plus rentables les
entreprises commerciales se déportent
alors automatiquement vers les activités
offrant des taux de rentabilité
inférieure
la question est de savoir comment
aujourd'hui permettre le développement
d'une offre satisfaisant la demande pour
les secteurs les moins rentables
inévitablement
l'instrument fiscal apparaît le plus
approprié c'est ce que vous faites en
rendant les entreprises de l'ESS ou
bénéficiant de l'agrément entreprise
solidaire éligible à certaines aides ou
exonération
sauf qu'ici les dispositions fiscales ne
seront pas déterminées par la faible
rentabilité de l'activité mais par le
statut juridique de l'offreur
si l'offreur est une association il
serait aidé si l'offreur est une
entreprise vous le taxerez aussi il
conviendra rappeler la politique
gouvernementale en matière d'aide à la
personne et notamment sur l'absence de
cohérence du gouvernement en effet mes
chers collègues suite à la mise en
demeure en France par l'Europe vous avez
fait passer le taux de TVA de certains
services à la personne de 7 à
19,6%. et cela seulement quelques mois
après le passage de 5,5 à 7%
nous sommes mes chers collègues dont
bien loin de Lionel Jospin qui avait
justement considéré qu'à l'activité
équivalente développée dans les
conditions similaires les associations
du secteur non lucratif et les
entreprises commerciales devraient être
soumises au même imposition
le gouvernement
actuel a publié un décret de 19 juin
dernier exonérant les associations sans
butatives du secteur de cette hausse de
taux
cela commence à faire beaucoup pour les
entreprises commerciales pour cette
raison et même si nous admettons que les
sculptures non commerciales soient aidés
cela nous semble relever du dogmatisme
en ce qui concerne les informations des
salariés afin de leur accorder une
situation privilégiée dans les
négociations peut-être que dans certains
cas cela facilitera la transmission de
l'entreprise aux salariés sous forme de
Scop mais ce combat pour quelques
symboles nous sommes se faire en
sacrifiant l'intérêt bien compris de
l'immense majorité des propriétaires et
des salariés l'information des salariés
existent déjà dans les entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés pour celle de moins
de 50 la réalité des relations
propriétaires salariés conduit
inévitablement à la transmission de
l'information
encore une fois nous allons rendre la
loi encore un peu plus verbaleuse comme
l'a dit le président Larcher hier ici
même en ce qui concerne le risque de
divulgation de cette information vous ne
pouvez pas faire semblant de l'ignorer
vous semblez ne pas croire aux dangers
que représente cette divulgation par
l'issue des négociations mais comment
pouvez-vous croire que les mouvements
sociaux déclenchés préventivement ne
retarderons pas les négociations
lorsqu'ils ne les arrêteront pas comment
ne pas se poser la question des
fournisseurs et des clients dans le
seeur dans le sort pardon est lié à ces
entreprises enfin pourquoi permettre aux
salariés de réaliser une offre au moment
même où le prix de vente est le plus
élevé
pour ces raisons nous nous opposons
également à l'information préalable des
salariés selon les conditions énoncées
par le gouvernement cette disposition
comme la plupart de celles qui nous a
été donnée d'examiner témoin d'un
gouvernement qui sont vouloir se
rassurer ou alors peut-être se faire
plaisir nous associons donc tout cela à
la situation actuelle et pour conclure
ce texte tout simplement cela nous
semble une attaque en règle contre le
monde de l'entreprise et contre des
mêmes d'initiatives privées ce projet de
loi donc ne semble contenter que les
égaux je vous remercie de votre
attention et je m'excuse d'avoir été un
peu long mais pas dans longtemps je n'ai
pas pris la parole mes chers collègues
merci Monsieur Le Cam
ce Président c'est le Ministre chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
souligner l'esprit de construction qui
s'est établie dans la préparation de ce
texte construction à la fois
avec le ministère et son cabinet merci
Monsieur le Ministre ainsi qu'avec
monsieur Marc de Nice le rapporteur du
texte c'est assez rare si je puis dire
pour être souligné et nous ne sommes pas
des ingrats nous avons apprécié
de cet article de vie nous ne doutons
pas que d'un mal peut venir un bien et
que demain à l'issue du débat à
l'Assemblée nationale ces valeurs
exemplaires si je puis dire reviendront
par la fenêtre si elles sont sorties par
la porte donc nous sommes confiants et
nous allons voter ce texte pour deux
raisons la première c'est que l'économie
sociale et solidaire fait partie des
fondamentaux des idées du parti auquel
j'appartiens depuis toujours il s'agit
bien sûr de la participation des
salariés à leur entreprise je dis leur
entreprise qu'elle leur appartiennent ou
qu'elle leur appartiennent pas des
salariés qui sont dans une entreprise
depuis 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans voire plus
considère que cette entreprise c'est
aussi la leur et on s'en aperçoit
notamment quand il se retrouve licencié
souvent on leur a demandé des efforts
particuliers pour sauver l'entreprise et
quelquefois elle se casse malgré tout la
figure il s'en trouve d'autant plus
déprimé face à cette situation et une
deuxième raison je pense que ce texte
sortira beaucoup plus fort du Sénat en
étant voté positivement il arrivera à
l'Assemblée nationale dans une bonne
situation et je ne doute pas que le
travail des députés contribuera
également à améliorer à donner vigueur à
ce texte qui est porteur d'avenir pour
les l'ensemble des salariés et cela
n'enlève rien au mérite de tous les
patrons qui soient de PME ou de grandes
entreprises dans certains cas qui sont
aussi tout à fait méritants mais je
crois que c'est un ensemble c'est une
complémentarité à laquelle je voulais
que je voulais saluer voilà donc nous
voterons ce texte merci
si Monsieur le cas monsieur Val
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues bien
qu'elles n'ayant pas pu participer à une
partie de ces débats sur ce projet de
loi relative à l'économie sociale et
solidaire je suis convaincu de
l'importance de texte et le rapporteur
vient de l'exprimer tout à l'heure en
disant que ce test était historique je
le rejoins et je pense comme l'a dit mon
collègue monsieur Lecan il est
historique parce que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'il faut te sexe dans cette
conjoncture dans cette période que nous
avons à traverser aussi difficile mon
groupe le RDSE a fortement contribué à
ces améliorations je pense en
particulier aux amendements défendus par
Jacques mesard les articles 11 et 12 qui
ont reçu un soutien quasi unanime et qui
vise à sécuriser le dispositif
d'information des salariés prévu en
amont de la session de l'entreprise ces
mesures ont pour objectif le maintien de
l'activité et de l'emploi c'est pourquoi
nous y sommes très attachés elle
mériteront cependant comme nous l'avons
souligné d'être complété par des mesures
de formation et d'accompagnement des
salariés pour leur permettre d'être en
capacité de reprendre effectivement
leurs entreprises je me rejoins
également de l'adoption de notre
amendement sur les titres associatifs
qui permettra d'améliorer le financement
des associations tout en évitant de
possible dérives ou détournement de ce
dispositif enfin je viens de défendre
mon amendement qui constituent
l'innovation majeure en proposant une
définition légale du commerce équitable
je suis très heureux qu'il ait été
adopté même s'il nécessitera de sans
doute au cours de la navette
parlementaire des précisions et des
améliorations dans l'ensemble ce projet
de loi est très attendue par les acteurs
de l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
s'agit des familles traditionnelles ce
secteur que sont les coopératives les
associations les mutuelles les
fondations nous ne vous acteurs les
entreprises de l'économie sociale
solidaire société commerciale qui
respectent les conditions définies
l'articles premiers de ce projet de loi
cet article propose une définition
inclusive de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui doit permettre son
développement nous avons cherché par nos
amendements à préciser et en sécuriser
la rédaction mais nous sommes dans
l'ensemble très satisfait de la logique
qui soustence
je tiens à remercier tous les collègues
pour ce débat ça a été déjà souligné à
la fois constructif instructif ainsi que
le rapporteur et les trois rapporteurs
par avis qui ont fait un excellent
travail mais je voudrais aussi remercier
à mon tour le ministre pour son écoute
et ses réponses à nos interrogations et
à nos préoccupations confortés par cette
excellent travail réalisé au cours de
ces deux jours de débats et convaincu
des avancées que représente l'exposition
que nous avons adoptées l'ensemble des
membres du RSE voteront ce projet de loi
la monsieur Labé
le Président Monsieur le monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je vais faire
très rapidement
nous l'avons énoncé hier lors de la
discussion générale ma collègue Aline
Archambault je n'étais pas là hier pour
cause de climat breton qui est quelque
peu dans la tourmente donc nous nous
sommes satisfaits grandement de ce texte
de loi qui marque une grande avancée
dans pour le secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire une loi attendue
par les acteurs de terrain depuis de
nombreuses années les débats ont été
riches et fructueux et je tiens une
nouvelle fois à remercier le rapporteur
le travail du rapporteur marque de Nice
pour son ouverture au dialogue et son
excellent travail il est fort agréable
de travailler dans de telles conditions
je plaisantais ce matin avec mes
amendements qui se sont fait quelque peu
bouler mais c'est mais en fait on a
beaucoup travaillé en amont et par par
la Commission à intégrer beaucoup de nos
de nos propositions nous regrettons nous
aussi la disp de l'article de BIS
mettant en place une déclaration de
principes pour l'économie sociale et
solidaire nous sommes néanmoins très
satisfait du texte final et notamment de
l'adoption des articles 11 et 12
instaurant un droit d'information des
salariés et puis j'aurais apprécié le
final qui nous a apporté quelques
pépites de l'économie sociale et
solidaire portée par le commerce
équitable qui trouve enfin une
définition dans la loi voilà donc au nom
du groupe écologiste je voterais très
favorablement ce texte merci si je mets
dans le covoit l'ensemble du projet de
loi relatif à l'économie sociale et
solidaire quelles sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avis contraire
le projet de loi est adopté
vous l'avez vu les sénateur Renault
adopter ce projet de loi relatif à
l'économie sociale et solidaire un
projet de loi qui faisait relativement
consensus à gauche puisque socialiste
écologiste radicaux de gauche et
communiste ont tous voté pour tandis que
l'UMP et les centrist ont voté contre ce
qui posait problème et bien c'est
essentiellement les articles 11 et 12
article prévoyant à l'information
préalable des salariés en cas de session
d'une entreprise afin de favoriser le
rachat de cette entreprise par ces mêmes
salariés vous pouvez bien sûr toujours
voir et revoir toute la séance sur notre
site public sénat.fr prochain
rendez-vous de l'actualité parlementaire
cet après-midi 19h 24 heures Senna avec
Delphine Girard très bonne journée sur
la chaîne parlementaire